Õpetaja: Ee, plaanid on sellised, et ma olen teinud seda varasemalt enamvähem. Samamoodi, et me ei tee päris Fronti lõpuni selle projektiga, et ainult fronti,
Õpetaja: et järgmine nädal Me hakkame. Ikkagi hakkame pihta
Õpetaja: ja. Ja siis mingi hetk me jõuame. Me ütleme, hakkame neid teenuseid tegema, Mis meil siiamaani on olemas.
Õpetaja: Teeme neid ja siis mingi hetk. Me jõuame järgi. Vaata, et Frontis enam asju pole. Siis me teeme Packi asja ennem ära ja teeme Fronti peale. Vaata, on ju, et me läheme nagu päris sellele ka,
Õpetaja: et siin peamine. Eesmärk on see, et Kogu aeg oli see mure. Vaata, alguses ma lõpetasin backendi. Noh, see oli see. Mitte midagi nad aru ei saa. Jõudsime Frontini, Okei, Siis Nad said juba sellest asjast nagu enamvähem aru. Aga oli parem, et saaks fronti teha. Ja siis hakkas Niukene asi juhtuma, et üldiseid Kontseptsioone. Pluss Fronti circa. Kaks nädalat õpime.
Õpetaja: Siis Läheb ee Nädal läheb põhimõtteliselt backendi peale. Ja kui te hakkasite projekti tegema, siis oli niimoodi, Et Jälle nagu nädal aega oli pausi. Vaata, kui ei olnud Fronti teinud. Ja see on kuidagi hästi raske jälle nagu, Oot, oot,
Õpetaja: asjad Just hakkavad nagu kuidagi ee peas paika loksuma. Aga frontend? Ist on jälle nagu põmm. Kurat, kuidas see asi käis? Ja siis viimased paar Gruppi Juba oleme niimoodi teinud, et Ee, jätab natukene front. I asju
Õpetaja: jätab hoopis. Selleks ajaks, kui Ee Backendi oleme juba natukene õppinud ja Tuleme tagasi, et lõpus juba õpime. Jälle natuke. Nagu koos,
Õpetaja: et see hetk kui on nagu tõmbame joone niiöelda õpetustele akadeemilise õppimisele joone alla Ja nüüd hakata projekte tegema, siis te olete vahetult just ennem tegelikult mõlemal kogenud. Nii,
Õpetaja: Nii et, ee, uuest nädalast backend on mahuks nagu väiksem.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta on tegelikult mahud Väiksem selles mõttes, et, ee. Mingid kontseptsioonid. Me oleme juba ära katnud. Vaata, nagu, et noh muutuja, meetod,
Õpetaja: Objektid meil tegelikult juba kaetud. Vaata, on ju. Ee. Et selles mõttes on. Ja kui siin on Niukene virrvarr, template osa Datablokk eraldi põmm, Põmm, mitid
Õpetaja: ja mingid asjad lendavad üles Mingid asjad alla. Siis õnneks. Backendis on asi palju lihtsam. Selles mõttes et on Niukene palju ee, Ühtlasem Flow ei ole nii palju nagu erinevaid osakesi. Nagu, et seal on. Selles mõttes on see natukene nagu lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Jah, et me te Peategi mõtlema, et me tegelikult ei ei õpi Kaks nädalat Fronti, vaid me õpime kaks nädalat progemist ja Fronti
Õpetaja: ja nädal Siis jääb, meil Aa, peale, aga need kontseptsioonid on juba. Noh, hakkame tooma ka. Analooge, Ma ütlen, mäletate? Vaatame seal Frontis. Vaatame muuta, saab tuua nagu mingit analoogiad kogu aeg,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, selles mõttes on see,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes on. Ee, see on natukene lihtsam. Ja see. Ma ütlen, et ega See on siin palju mul neid gruppe oli. Ma just üks päev vaatasin kataloogidega.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, et kõikide nende gruppide jooksul on enamvähem Nagu paika loksunud Ee, süsteemis töötab
Õpetaja: Aa vahele. Mis tahaks veel teha, on ka. On see ee, et me hakkame tooma rohkem sisse sellel kujul ka, et ta teeb meile midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et seda hetke ma pigem taban ära kuskilt sealt. Ee, millal see, nagu niimoodi on? Teeme Ka Fronti lõpus juba. Ee, kui me tuleme tagasi Fronti, siis on mul plaan pigem ee kasutada. Ai D ja teha koodi
Õpetaja: ja siis õppida ja aru saada kuidas asjad, töötavad, Versus, et me teeme nullist,
Õpetaja: et ee. Kuskilt peab tulema see aeg nagu tagasi ka nii,
Õpetaja: ja Ma arvan, et see töötab. Ma arvan, et see tuleb päris. Ee, päris Okei, tuleb välja.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga lähme siis praegult edasi. Teine võib lahti. Kuidas olla, kui külma ei tunne
Õpetaja: Härrasmehed ka Sellest Teevad mind kohvi midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee hetkel nad ei ei pruummi.
Õpetaja: Mm, kas koordinaid panin käima või ei pannud, Panin, onju? Ja Screenshare on olemas. Jah,
Õpetaja: super. Super. Aa, kui me pooleli jäime. Noh, vaatab ka korra visuaali. Võibolla et
Õpetaja: vist jõudsime mingisuguse flow ära teha, Et see asi vähemalt tuleb meile ilusti. Sse on ju nii?
Õpetaja: City Id muutus,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on Siis nagu, et kuidas on siis nende asjadega, et hetkel alla asjad flowvad. Seda me juba nägime, et kui mina tulen siia datablokki selle Ele selle objekti peale. Kust kõik asjad elavad? Panen siin näiteks.
Õpetaja: Siis see siia tuleb. Aga nüüd on vaja siis, seda, et kuidas ta Siis hakkab sealt alt üles Tulema.
Õpetaja: No kõigepealt, Mis me teeme? Me lähemegi sinna päris sinna kohta, Kus see siis on? Lahti teha, otsida üles. Ee, siit. Location for. Näiteks. Ma panengi Close all, et oleks See on. Liigume alla.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd level. Kaks on meie Child Location Name on meil. Grandchild, on nii? Oled nõus?
Õpetaja: Nüüd me alustame oma teekonda. Loomulikult, sellespärast, et siin, on information välju
Õpetaja: see, mida input Tekst kuvab nagu need asjad mängivad kokku, on ju
Õpetaja: nüüd? Meil on vaja öelda, et. Hei, kui toimub mingisugune Mis asi, mis te mõtlete, Klikk Change.
Õpetaja: Saint Change võiks olla, on ju? Aga mis? Te arvate, millal Change on? Nagu Millal Change On nagu.
Õpetaja: Kui me mõtleme seda Nagu Input Boxiga. Vaata, paneme selle visuaali ette, et. Kas ma siia peale klikin Onchange?
Õpetaja: Pigem mitte, Kui ma kirjutan siia A tähega, see on Change siis üks korrekt
Õpetaja: või klikid kuskile mujale. Tegelikult see on Change, et siin on nagu see, et Change on see, et see ei ole compliit, enne kui See on nagu lõplik.
Õpetaja: Aga meie tahame pigem ee lisaks ka teha, aga pigem me ei soovi seda teha. No päeva lõpuks. Vaata lõpuks kui nuppu aitad, Lisa, siis sa lähed igal juhul selle pealt ära. Vahet pole, millises järjekorras sa neid täidad, On ju,
Õpetaja: et selle lisaajal on Change niikuinii muutunud, et saaks teha Change. No siis teeme seda nagu niimoodi. Step by step, onju, et Ma korra panen. Ee, teen siia. See on nagu pigem vaatamise koht. Ma panen siia korra methods bloki.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia. Lihtsalt, Ee, ärge seda kaasa tehke.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen siia. Hello ja ma panen siia lihtsalt alert. Hello.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt näeksime, et millal see nagu. Triggerdub, vaata et praegu see on. Selle input. Boxiga ei ole veel seotud, Aga nüüd ma teen. Seda
Õpetaja: Ät ma teen. Alustame lihtsalt Ät Click võrdub, Käivitaja Hello.
Õpetaja: No vaatame,
Õpetaja: klik. No ei taha, onju? Meil ei ole praegult andmeid. Midagi ei ole muutunud. Meil ei ole midagi üles limitida,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen selle Ad Change.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis nende pakub siin siis proovime uuesti. Klikin siia. Klikin siia ei tulnud talle ette. Kirjutan tähe,
Õpetaja: ei tule Kõiki. Mujale on hello.
Õpetaja: See idee järgi võiks töötada. Ka. Vaata, nagu, et see on nagu Fine, see lahendus juba meile tegelikult Ideeliselt sobiks.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aa. Selles mõttes, et on igasugused mingid Aa mobiilid. Ja asjad. Vaata, et kuidas sa seal nagu, kas on mingi brauseri eripära
Õpetaja: pigem Tahaksin sellist lähenemist, et iga täht triggerdaks juba muutuse ei jõuaks reaalajas ülesse. Location objekti
Õpetaja: ja tagasi alla ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, alla Ta jõuab niikuinii läbi propside kui üleval. Location punkt Aa Location Name muutub.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ta igal juhul Flow vaata onju aga kuidas ta siin ülesse saadab
Õpetaja: nüüd siin. Selle kohta tuleb appi niuke. Asi nagu inpot.
Õpetaja: Tema nüüd jälgib niimoodi, et iga niiöelda täht, mis siia toksitakse, on input. Vaatame, Teeme Refresh
Õpetaja: Klikin siia kuskile mujale. Korra Klikin siia. Kas Hello tuli?
Õpetaja: Üritan, A.
Õpetaja: Ütlen B, et ei olnud saate mõttes tarbijal.
Õpetaja: See on pigem lähenemine. Me soovime kasutada. See on kõik siin Brauseri sees, et siin ei ole mõelda midagi, et oo mingit protsessorit koormavad Või midagi Taolist. Vaata, et see on ülisavi.
Õpetaja: See on siis ee, asünkroonne.
Õpetaja: Sellest lihtsalt ei piisa, et me nagu saadame need andmed, siis Kui me vajutame Lisa,
Õpetaja: Jah, sest et me tegelikult soovime. Meil on. Vaata missioon. Ära unusta, ära, kuidas saab input oma tegelikku sisu vaata,
Õpetaja: Ta saab Kainda nagu see, mis sa trükid.
Õpetaja: Aga tema ju tahab ju Seda, et põhimõtteliselt, et see asi ja see sisu on nagu sünkroonis. Aga hetkel ei ole ju,
Õpetaja: et kui mina panen, vaatame ka ära. Tuleme. Teeme selle Pro selle, Noh, teen puhtalt lehelt,
Õpetaja: teen, aga Tegelikult siit samast saab ka lahti teha, kui ma võtan selle Location I lahti. Location formi ja location input i location Name hetkel, mis See on
Õpetaja: tühi, on ju? Kui ma panen siia A,
Õpetaja: siis jah. Visuaalselt me siin näeme. Aga Propsi sisu on endiselt
Õpetaja: tühi, Isegi kui Me Saadame saadame tühja all sellepärast. Jah,
Õpetaja: me tahame. Iga me lõppeesmärk on niikuinii. Vaata, et Noh Lõppeesmärk on see, et siin Location Is oleks See nimi, mis sisse toksitakse läbi mitme korruse. Siit hakkame tulema. Üks, Kaks, kolm, on ju? See on Siuke. Lõplik plaan,
Õpetaja: aga vaata, Meil on praegult koodi tasandil öeldud. Vaata, et tema sisu on see, mis sisse, Flow, et siin on nagu väike vasturääkivus, et visuaalselt siin on see A,
Õpetaja: aga Tegelikult on tühjus siin Location Namil, et seda tuleb nüüd sünkroonis hoida, nagu nii,
Õpetaja: et lõppeesmärk on tõesti see, et Meil tegelikult täiesti piisab üldse sellest, et kui me vajutame seda nuppu, Lisa, et sellel hetkel me need andmed saame. Vaata, on ju, aga Me ei soovi. Nii. Me soovime kogu aeg hoida seda objekti igal juhul reaktiivselt niiöelda korras.
Õpetaja: Nii, siis mis me teemegi, ongi see, et Siin ongi see Input On ju, et input trigerdub siis iga input i peale, nagu saadab midagi
Õpetaja: nüüd seda meetodit. Ma koristan siit ära, Seda hellod ei ole vaja,
Õpetaja: vaid mis me siin peame tegema? Noh, mis on see tööriist, Kui Me Childist soovime? Midagi
Õpetaja: ei, mitte onju Ja nüüd on jälle, et me saaksime teha meetodi. Aga see tuleb nii lihtne. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: sul pole point i Noh, siis paneksime niimoodi, et Alustame ka imitiga.
Õpetaja: Tal on see dollari märk. Ka seda ei pea ise otsima. Saab niimoodi Tabiga selle kätte.
Õpetaja: Temal on siin kaks poolt Event ja Argument
Õpetaja: Event name. Leppisime kokku, et meie Event Id ikkagi on Event. Iga hakkab pihta, Event.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: nüüd me mõtleme nagu, kuidas me ülevalt seda loeme. Vaata, et ülevalt me loeme, et siin mingi sündmus juhtus. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ma pannaksin näiteks niimoodi Location nii Change
Õpetaja: ja ma Räägin, et see, kuidas mina neid kutsun, ei ole nüüd see, kuidas võibolla tavapraktikas tehakse, et kuidas mis sõnu kasutatakse, kuidas ja nii edasi See on see, kuidas Mulle meeldib.
Õpetaja: Kuidas?
Õpetaja: Hästi lihtne, aga vaata. Ei, ma ei saa veel aru. Räägi uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ee, no, siin on te Selles tegusõna tähenduses Pigem nagu ma võiksin siia panna siis nagu geneerilisemalt.
Õpetaja: Vaata, me näeme. Me. Me peame mõtlema seda, Vaata, et see Event, Vaata, mis me siia paneme. Tuleb lõpuks meil siia, et Location form. Me tahame kunagi öelda. Vaata, me oleme Location Use Me oleme see Grand Parentes. Me tahame, et see kõnetaks meid siin,
Õpetaja: Et siin ei ole vaja liiga tehniliseks minna. Vaid Siin on vaja mõelda lihtsalt see, Et kuidas ma saan aru, mis?
Õpetaja: Mis sündmus alt tuli?
Õpetaja: Event Location name up data,
Õpetaja: et Niukene sündmus tuleb alt ja ma saaksin öelda, et Tee nüüd midagi. See on see, plaan,
Õpetaja: et mida iganes me mõtleme, et kuidas see meid kõige paremini just siin kõnetab,
Õpetaja: No kuidas Ta oli praegu. Ta oligi niimoodi. No ütleme, Nagu Kuidas ta kõnetab. Me oleme Location Views. Meil on Location Forum.
Õpetaja: See sõnum on ad Location Name Change. Update
Õpetaja: mulle, siis update Id. Isegi meeldib rohkem kokku ka midagi, kui tahate
Õpetaja: Ma tean, et päriselt tegelikult võiks see ka mingi niimoodi olla. Vaata, et et ma olen näinud mingeid niukseid. Sõnumeid, nagu update Kool on.
Õpetaja: Oi, aga ta tahab kohe kasutada mingeid sõnu, Seda pigem mitte,
Õpetaja: aga vaata, see nagu käsib. Vaata, onju? Aga minule
Õpetaja: minule ei meeldi Mina tahan saada aru, mis juhtus.
Õpetaja: See on käsk, Vaata, nagu mulle meeldib ikkagi nii.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et see variant on kõige paremgi,
Õpetaja: sest et siis teistel on ka kogu aeg update, Vahet, pole. Kes on transaction types, või mis iganes update.
Õpetaja: No võibolla pikalt paneks niimoodi
Õpetaja: ja siin oleks üldse küsimus. Vaata, et kas me, kui Me saame süntaksist niikuinii aru. Vaata, kas selle Event Il on üldse mõtet. Nagu Point I Vaata, on ju Aga mul õppimise mõttes tundub, et niimoodi on hea
Õpetaja: et sündmus oli. Sest sa tead tehnoloogias. Vaata, see. See on sündmus. Midagi juhtub
Õpetaja: ja. Ja et ma ütlen nagu, Päris Production is. Ma pakun, et ee, oleks kuidagi lühemad ja teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ütlen ka jällegi. Vaata, see on täpselt, see vaata, et Mitte keegi ei keela nagu teha asju niimoodi nagu meie tiimina. Nagu Arvame, et me tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Aga tähtis on muidugi see, et käekiri On Kogu aeg sama, mis iganes võetakse vastu otsus. Siis Sellega nagu pannakse edasi või muudetakse kõik igal pool ära. Aga ei ole niimoodi, Et nagu Juku teeb ühtepidi ja juhan teistpidi. Vaata Ja siis. Mai. Kahjuks peab seda lugema. On ju
Õpetaja: jüko ühene vaip nii. No. Selle Ma kustutan praegu siit ära. Selle Me oleme siin esimesel korrusel
Õpetaja: Või need järjestada ka teistpidi. Vaata, et, ee, Child pärand.
Õpetaja: Me tahame, et Andmed voolaksid siit ülesse siia. See on plaan
Õpetaja: varem. See location name. Ma flirdin korra. Vaata, võibolla võib mõelda. Ma ei tea, kuidas teid kõnetab jälle. Te peate seda mõtlema Nagu selles kontekstis. Kus te lõpuks näete seda
Õpetaja: kohvriga? Üldse Programm
Õpetaja: Kuna me lõpuks, mida me hakkame, muutma, on Location is Ee objektis Location Name siis. Noh, ma pakun, et see võiks olla mingi enamvähem kompromiss
Õpetaja: oli Üldse ka võibolla halb nagu Vaata, et update,
Õpetaja: nagu hakkab. Võibolla natukene seda ad change I ka meenutama, onju?
Õpetaja: Võibolla see sõna nagu siis kuidagi hitib teda,
Õpetaja: et las ta olla siis niimoodi. Lihtsalt input. Ei taha panna, et kuidagi see kõneviis.
Õpetaja: Ee, tundub niimoodi kõige õigem. Nii, nüüd see on sündmus, ise Aga meid tegelikult huvitab see välju,
Õpetaja: mis on siin küljes.
Õpetaja: See on läbi atribuudi pandud. See on elemendi enda küljes.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on see, Koht, kus me saame öelda, et
Õpetaja: tahaks paki kaasa panna. Ee, kõik mis Me saame alati kätte Input, ist. Vahet pole, on see Date, On see ee number? On see fail mida iganes. Tegelikult ta tuleb strengina. See sisu
Õpetaja: meile sobib. See et ta läheb String ina ülesse Location Name siis seda. Seda asja ei ole vaja teha. Vaata, et. Oot, me peame hakkama mingit asja numbriks tegema, Aga see on see, koht, kus me mõtleme sellele,
Õpetaja: kas on, mida me saadame? Kas on mingi objekt, mida me saadame? Kas see on mingi. On see number, Seda võiks mõelda sellepärast, et paneks kohe õiges formaadis selle asja teele, et me ei pea kuskilt üleval hakkama seda Fixima,
Õpetaja: ja siis see Taaskasutus on ka nagu reaalne. Nagu et me pea iga kord Fixima seda
Õpetaja: nii meie naabrit ei taha saata. Me tahame taas ringi saata. Kus me selle kätte saame?
Õpetaja: Sündmuse enda küljest.
Õpetaja: See ongi sündmus. Kui keegi midagi kirjutab sinna,
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja öelda, nagu, et mis on See osa sellest Event ist, mis meid huvitab, Mis on meie sihtmärk?
Õpetaja: Meie sihtmärk on see atribuut. Valuve Mäletate Checkboxil on checkt siin. Meid huvitab value Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd praegult hetkel. Aa, nüüd, võiks et oleks viisakas, et oleks viisakas emits,
Õpetaja: et oleks viisakas. Parem Ei, see oli massiiv, Mits saab panna niimoodi
Õpetaja: copy maja? Lihtsalt et näed, niukene Sündmus läheb Siis on nagu, et dokumenteeritud on,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, minu soovitus on see. Vaata, et praegult kuuse mitt läheb. Kui see on Child Parent.
Õpetaja: Grand Parent ta läheb siia, on ju? On nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina nagu Nüüd soovitan teha niukse Väikse triki.
Õpetaja: Räägi, teeme nagu pikalt ikka. Võta, Võtame rahulikult selle nime
Õpetaja: ja tuleme nüüd siia.
Õpetaja: See Siin on, sisend, Mis läheb alla
Õpetaja: nüüd tasuks teha? Juurde. No, selle võib korra siia reale panna. Siis lüüa uuele reale. Ta ei mahu niikuinii ära.
Õpetaja: Läheb uuele reale. Ütleme, et. Noh. Ütleme nii, et kui ta on.
Õpetaja: Kui te olete Niukses hetkes, et ta ei ole veel paste inud, tehke üks
Õpetaja: Space vahele siia ja lükake see lihtsalt uuele reale alla. Aga see ka siis ütlevad, onju?
Õpetaja: Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Meil ongi. Me jätame need asjad mis lähevad alla siia ettepoole. Sündmused tulevad, aga midagi ununes.
Õpetaja: Ät See on hästi tähtis.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd võrdlusmärgiga. Siis on see, et vot mis nüüd siis saama Peab hakkama, onju?
Õpetaja: No, me tegelikult peame nüüd tegema seda sama asja uuesti.
Õpetaja: Me peame lihtsalt uuesti miittima edasi,
Õpetaja: me võime võtta selle sisu, mis on siin.
Õpetaja: Aga ärge unustage ära. Vaata, Siin läks pakiga kaasa. Mitte terve vend. Te olete nõus, vaid ainult üks osa vendist Namely Value. Seda tuleb meeles hoida. Me saame Copy Paste siit. Selle osa,
Õpetaja: mis on nende jutumärkide vahel
Õpetaja: tulla panna siia järgmisesse boksi, et ei saada ülesse. Teade, bla, bla, bla, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga ärge unusta ära nüüd. See event, mis alt tuleb, ongi juba Target Value
Õpetaja: Eelmine kiht ei saatnud tervet event. I. Me ei saada tervet event i edasi. Koguaeg saate aru vaid ainult väikse osa sellest,
Õpetaja: sest siin Kihis me juba ei viska edasi. Ee, see. Sest siin ongi juba välju. Siin ongi juba see string. See Event ise ongi. Nüüd String.
Õpetaja: Viskame ainult niimoodi selle vend i ülesse.
Õpetaja: See ongi juba see väärtus.
Õpetaja: Siin on pakk. Ei saada. Vot vot see vahe oleks see. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: Kuigi, viskaks see venti ja küll siis peaks viskama venti Ja lõpuks tuled. Võtad target välju. Aga Seal pole Point I sa nagu Meetoditel ka. Sa annad kaasa ainult seda, mis on vaja.
Õpetaja: Siin. Selles pakist, on meil vaja ainult seda väärtust sisse. Soovime. Location Name. Ainult Me ei soovi location objekti. Kus küljes on? Name? Aa, ma lihtsalt siia. String location. Name. Las Siia sisse. Voolab see asi välja, Saadan Selle value,
Õpetaja: mis iganes seal sees saab olema, nii.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd selle viskab siit edasi. Mul midagi,
Õpetaja: lihtsalt viska edasi ja vend tuleb sama nimi
Õpetaja: vanasti Voe kahes oli üks ee. Üks lihtne sõna, millega põhimõtteliselt sai öelda. Et Viska kõik, mis alt tuleb. Viska edasi, aga nad Võtsid selle ära? Aa, alates voe kahest. Juba. Minu meelest ta kadus juba ära. Isegi mitte enne kolme. Minu arust ta võttis Kadus ära Kuhugi või kahega. Kadus kindlasti ära, et kolmega enam ei olnud.
Õpetaja: Ilmselt saadi aru, et see on liiga ohtlik. Viska kõik sündmused üles, edasi,
Õpetaja: Siit võib palju venti tulla. No ja siin oleks samamoodi. Vaata, et siin all ju peaks ju tegelikult ära määrama,
Õpetaja: mis? Mitte siit, läheb et Hetkel me saaksime tulla siia ja võtta lihtsalt selle
Õpetaja: koma. Ja mits niimoodi, et? Noh,
Õpetaja: defineerime selle siia vormi ka ära vaata, et Näed, see
Õpetaja: see tegelane Hetkel Ainult tuli. Kogemata topeltnäit,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, et see niukest Event I, et siis ma ei peaks seda templetit üldse Vaatamegi. Ma juba tean,
Õpetaja: mida ta sisse võtab ja mida ta teeb.
Õpetaja: Ja Siin on see lihtsam formaat, kus ei räägita sellest objektist ja Tema tüübist Mitte ööde ega mütsi, onju? Meil sobib see
Õpetaja: nüüd.
Õpetaja: Me oleme nüüd siin poolel. Teel on ju, et seda siit
Õpetaja: input i Muudatuse peale. Saadame vend I koos
Õpetaja: selle input i välju väärtusega. Okei, siit tuleb Event.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, mis teed. Viska üks uus Event
Õpetaja: ja kaasa Pane mis iganes alt tuli see tähendab, mis iganes. Alt tuli paki edasiviskamine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis me soovime, on Ee,
Õpetaja: Jah, jälle põhimõtteliselt kandis see osa Siin sa. See on Event Lisenar
Õpetaja: Cool Event. I nimega Location Event Location Name Outpot. Selle võime copida
Õpetaja: ja nüüd me tuleme Lõpuks Siia tulevad sõnumid alla. Läheb lihtsalt location objekt
Õpetaja: Me jälle teeme siia ruumi. Paneme Control V.
Õpetaja: Lööme ta siia alla. Niimoodi selle tag. I Kolm kolmnurk noole. Mis iganes, lükkame alla siia, Paneme võrdusmärgi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina küsin siin, et mis nüüd siis peab Juhtuma? Alt tuleb pakikene alati nõus. Kuidas kätte saab
Õpetaja: Sõnaga Event? Millel on see dollari märk?
Õpetaja: Siin sees on nüüd see väärtus. Nüüd on küsimus, et mis me selle väärtusega tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Kord
Õpetaja: võrdub. Kus ma selle võrdlusmärgi panen? Event I järgi, et Event tuleb alt mingisuguse sisuga ja ma annan talle nüüd siin omakorda mingi uue sisu vä
Õpetaja: ja. Ja me tahame selle väärtust anda. Aga kuhu me tahame selle väärtust panna?
Õpetaja: Talt tuleb siit kastist, Tuleb ju sisu. Aa, kuhu see? Aa peab? Minema?
Õpetaja: Nii, selleks.
Õpetaja: Ei, see on mingi destination. Mis sa räägid? Ei, serverist ei Räägi, midagi, Kuhu ta praegu peab minema Ta praegu. Ta elab, ja sureb siin ära.
Õpetaja: Ja location alla läheb ju. Kogu see kupatus. Vaata, näe alla läheb. Kogu see asi
Õpetaja: voolab alla. Ma olen mitu korda vaadanud. Tema läheb tühjusega. Aga Nüüd on nagu see, et ta jääbki tühjuseks, mida Meie tahame öelda, et kuule sealt alt tuleb meile sellest kastist. Sisu. See peab minema
Õpetaja: siia.
Õpetaja: Siia peab minema, onju? Location i location name I on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii? No aga siis siin saamegi niimoodi kirjutada. Ma korra kustutan selle ära, et mis ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Ei, me ainult Skrip I sees Location punkt location. Name edasi korda.
Õpetaja: Anname talle uue sisu.
Õpetaja: Ja mis me anname talle?
Õpetaja: Jah, hakkate Event I lihtsalt kirjutama, Siis tulge siia. Otsige põmm tehtud.
Õpetaja: Jällegi sellest saaks teha eraldi meetodi. Näiteks Location Ee Name Set Location Location Name. Näiteks saaks eraldi meetod. Ei tee,
Õpetaja: aga selline inline on tegelikult. Üsna
Õpetaja: Event. Kui te vaatate Event Location name, update. Ahah, okei, siuke sündmus. Location Name sai uue Sisu, mis me teeme, siis me ütleme. Location punkt saab uue sisu.
Õpetaja: Ahah. Noh, normaalne.
Õpetaja: Väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin vanasti. Siin tegin eraldi meetodit Settermeetodi. Aga mõttetu.
Õpetaja: Milleks seda meetodit vaja on, Kui seal on veel midagi vaja teha. See on teine küsimus,
Õpetaja: kui on midagi rohkem action It, mis siia ära ei kirjuta.
Õpetaja: No ega Nüüd siis polegi rohkem midagi. Põhimõtteliselt, et vaatame, kas see töötab. Nagu
Õpetaja: panen siia vaikeväärtusega. Sisse Teen lahti juba selle poksi, et nagu näha, nagu.
Õpetaja: Mis siin Location I sees toimub.
Õpetaja: Location name on mingisuguse suvalise väärtusega, kui mina kirjutan siia. Aa, noh, tuleb toimib.
Õpetaja: Sa praegu paneksid Lisa Siis Üks asi on olemas, eksole?
Õpetaja: Davai, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Mis Nüüd siis edasi?
Õpetaja: Tuleb vist võtta Järgmine.
Õpetaja: Vaatame Location Name. Vabandust, Location Form on selle kinnisele veel. Eelmise asja. Pärand võib jääda.
Õpetaja: Selle vist tegime ära, on ju me selle kinni panna.
Õpetaja: Nüüd vist oleks alla. Läheb Location I number of Fatms. Info.
Õpetaja: Tahaks seda ülesse ka saada. Kätte lähme. Numbers of number of Atms Input I.
Õpetaja: Mis ma siin nüüd teen? Siis Öelge. Tee mulle, mis reale, lähen. Mida kirjutan, mida teen.
Õpetaja: Ma olen uus arendaja. Palun näidake, kuidas ma. Mis ma tegema pean. Öelge lihtsalt ette, mulle palun.
Õpetaja: Ei pea isegi mind õpetama, sest veel ketta
Õpetaja: input. Ile ütlen Ätt, Vaata, mis ätt. Ma ütlen, et infot
Õpetaja: paneme võrdusmärgi, et. No mis siis juhtuma peab hakkama. Mis peab juhtuma hakkama Juba pakkus ka Siin tegelikult see
Õpetaja: ei ole. Ettevend.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt on. Ah ja mit tuleb teha Ja see on tegevus Käivita tegevus. See on meetod Meetodil on Parameetreid.
Õpetaja: Noh, siia tuleb nüüd panna mingi string nimena või? Korra võib teha, niimoodi. Et no saab võtta, et nagu, et see oleks sama Muster
Õpetaja: võib teha niimoodi, korra, et võtab selle, aga saab ka kirjutada. Lihtsalt saate kirjutada
Õpetaja: Event Location Name Data Aga siin. Paneme event,
Õpetaja: mis ma kirjutan. No mis siin apteeni me siis? Mis siia sisse? Tuleb?
Õpetaja: Sest et me tahame, et meil oleks mingisugune muster, et me saame asjadest nagu struktuurist aru, nagu. Et mis toimub? Event Number of Data.
Õpetaja: See Mittil on kaks osa.
Õpetaja: Üks on event name ja teine on See, et pane pakk teele.
Õpetaja: Nii, öelge nüüd, palun tee ja mulle nüüd tähtaed, Mida ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on paki saatmine.
Õpetaja: No, ma Võin selle dollari märgi panna
Õpetaja: kui ma leian selle ülesse? Loomulikult näe Ee, Control alt. Ja neli Vist on minu keyboard. Il
Õpetaja: Noh, Mis edasi, Davai, Olge, mis sa räägid, Triin?
Õpetaja: Midagi räägib. Inimene pobiseb. Mu naine? Vihkab, kui mina näiteks midagi niukest. Teen Ee, target.
Õpetaja: Aa, Mis asi? Mis asi Target Number of Htm. Html. Il ei ole niukest asja nagu Number of Htms.
Õpetaja: Me räägime nendest atribuutidest, kui ma Tahaks Class i taipei.
Õpetaja: Vot need on targetid. Event il See event tuleb sellest input ist. Ma ütlen Event Anna mulle. Selle input. Iga Mingi asi
Õpetaja: mind huvitab.
Õpetaja: Value.
Õpetaja: No okei, mis selle kohta?
Õpetaja: Mis asi?
Õpetaja: Okei, ma pean, Ee, teeme siis teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: No, ma ei saa neid Päris ühele joonele. Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: ma mõtlesin. Siis Ma võtan kontrol setiga nüüd tagasi. Oodake üks hetk.
Õpetaja: Oi, kujutad Said kontod sealt Jah,
Õpetaja: ma Nüüd näitan nüüd nagu nii. Ee, võtame korra selle.
Õpetaja: No ma panen teised as kinni.
Õpetaja: Meil on kaks täpselt samasugust koodi.
Õpetaja: Te hakkasite pakkuma Mõlemad siin, kõik valete asja ja olete segaduses.
Õpetaja: Klient aitab, kui oled segaduses.
Õpetaja: Natukene Zoom. Ime sisse ka.
Õpetaja: Parem veel vaadata kuidagi väga häguseks Läks see asi?
Õpetaja: Keerame lihtsalt ära. Ee, input I atribuudid. Mis on hetkel kasutusel?
Õpetaja: Sa ostab tõele, et meil on input il value atribuuti kasutatud Taipei.
Õpetaja: Mingi min on siin. Glass,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Need on seotud selle inputiga. Html Tasandil
Õpetaja: on nii? Siin on näiteks ka value
Õpetaja: Taipe Class Place Shoulder on. Nii Need on Html i atribuudid.
Õpetaja: Nendel atribuutidel saavad olla väärtused ja sisu.
Õpetaja: Kui meie ütleme, vaata, et see Event Target,
Õpetaja: siis see target. Nüüd ütleb, et palun räägi, mida sa tahad. Kas sa tahad Taipei kätte saada?
Õpetaja: Mis võrduks numbert? Kas sa tahad Minni kätte saada. Mis võrduks Üks Näed, me teeme teist värvi.
Õpetaja: See siin ütleb, et anna mulle mis iganes on praegult selles kastis, palju me Ei, räägi sellest siin
Õpetaja: see samamoodi siin kõrval räägib niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kui meil tuleb, võtame korra lahti selle viimase Asja
Õpetaja: Transaction. Ee, Type Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Paneme korra selle kinni. Ei, ma panen talle isegi lahti.
Õpetaja: Kus on siin veel infot?
Õpetaja: Siin on, on ju? See on Checkbox. See On See saate, ära onju?
Õpetaja: Kas siin on mingi. Ee, Kas siin on? Teen selle pildi. Vaata uuesti, Palju puudub.
Õpetaja: Palju puudub.
Õpetaja: Siin veel ju puudub.
Õpetaja: Kus on siin välja.
Õpetaja: Öelge mulle, siin. Ei olegi välja. Siin on
Õpetaja: meil. Lõpuks on vaja teada, et Kuule, kas on True või Falls
Õpetaja: on checkt või? Ei ole? Checked.
Õpetaja: On ju siis siin? Meil ei ole Event. Target
Õpetaja: Value ei ole Event Target. Mingi transaction type, Või mida iganes meil on. Event Target
Õpetaja: checkt. Anna mulle selle vendi küljest selle asja väärtust. Kas te nüüd saate aru, kuidas see asi töötab.
Õpetaja: Seo need asjad. Siin on inputiga seotud atribuudid
Õpetaja: Nendele me saame ligi Event Punkt Target.
Õpetaja: Need asjad huvitavad meid. Meid huvitab, mis siin taga on, Aga me ei küsi.
Õpetaja: Me ei küsi neid nende asjadega. Mis on voe teema. See on puhas voeteema. See on mingi ee Need Muutujad. See siin.
Õpetaja: Ma ei kasuta neid.
Õpetaja: Me kasutame.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab otsa. Mul see target väljuda, aga ma tahtsin tuua
Õpetaja: niimoodi. Ma teen Control Set Control set. Kui neil on see vana pilt siin ees.
Õpetaja: Näete,
Õpetaja: sellest käib juttu.
Õpetaja: Näete, sellest? Käib jutt,
Õpetaja: mis on siin kastis, See välju ongi interaktiivselt seotud. Mis iganes on kasti sees, meie tuleme siia, siia, Sellesse inputi. Ütleme, et Hei,
Õpetaja: saa. Sina. Mis iganes sisu tuleb.
Õpetaja: Tahtsin joont ümber teha, et sa väljuks. Näita kastis, mis tuleb. Number Ftm Ist, mis tuleb meil ülevalt sisse
Õpetaja: väljub, väljub.
Õpetaja: See on Selle
Õpetaja: Html elemendi spetsiaalne atribuut, mis temal on, väljub sellel checkboxil, Mis me siin nüüd näitasime Korra Temal ei olegi niukest atribuuti nagu välju
Õpetaja: Näed, checkboxil ei ole välju.
Õpetaja: Ja tal ei saagi olla, et see ei anna meile mitte midagi. Ta ei anna meile true. We false, Kui siin. Klõbistad neid Checkt, on see, mis annab True We Falls.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi. Küll saab seda harjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis siin me saame, aru, et meid huvitab Mõlemal juhul Need on. Mõlemad on trükitavad kastid ja välju määrab selle ära. Mis on kasti sees ja välju on See, Mille kaudu me saame küsida, et. Kuule, anna mulle sisu.
Õpetaja: Nii Nüüd paneme selle kinni.
Õpetaja: Teen uuesti lahti selle vormi. Vaata, see on See järgmine korrus
Õpetaja: siia, mis tuleks alla lisada, on jälle see, et see event selle saab rottida kuskilt
Õpetaja: tulla. Korra öelda, et näed Emit Ib. Mida tema? Defineerime ära, et tema emit Ib seda
Õpetaja: Event I. See on dokumen dokumenteerimine. Kui Templeti. Panen kinni. Kas me teame, mida See komponent emiitib.
Õpetaja: Teame sest, et siin on ära defineeritud. Mis limitid siit võivad teele minna?
Õpetaja: Kas lähevad või ei lähe? See ei ole, See see on see, et mis siit võib minna,
Õpetaja: sest et mõnel komponendil võib olla mitu erinevat. Ee event I, mis võivad juhtuda
Õpetaja: ja Üks mõni pruugib juhtuda ja mõni ei pruugi. Ja mõni juhtub ühes olukorras mõni teises olukorras. See on see, et nagu kogu lubatused, mis Siit maksimumina võib välja minna.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on siis see, et. Hea küll, et meie sellest Grandchild ist läheb see asi teele,
Õpetaja: siis me Võtame jälle selle stringi sisu. Ilma nende märkideta
Õpetaja: on. Ütleme samamoodi. Number Ftms. Il info voolab alla, aga üles ei tule.
Õpetaja: Võibolla lööb sellele Uuele reale Selle paneb siia väikse vahe
Õpetaja: Paneb selle ka siia alla. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: Me saame öelda, et ei kuule, kui alt tuleb Event number Of Data.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, me rotime ei Viitsi võtab kogu selle asja siit.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi paneb nende jutumärkide asemel
Õpetaja: ja ainukene asi, mis nüüd, muutub. Oi, aga midagi läks valesti. Parem teha käsitsi.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma teen lihtsalt kiirelt uuesti. Tegelt see ei ole üldse raske. Vaata, Aa, ätt on puudu. Muidugi
Õpetaja: ta ei saa aru et see on Event. Nüüd ta saab aru.
Õpetaja: Võin selle kiirelt ka teha. No vaata, kui palju läheb aega. Hakka kirjutama. Panen sulud. Panen siia need jutumärgid. Kopeerin kiirelt selle siit. Panen selle siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Panen siit koma. Hakkan Event kirjutama, tulen Valin dollariga märgi
Õpetaja: Ja ongi tehtud. On ju, et ega siin erilist kirjutamist pole ka. Vot see ongi see. Üks. Te peate ka ühel hetkel ära tegema. Ärge jääge. Näiteks Copy pasteijateks. Tegelikult trükkides saad ta kiiremini. Pluss mõttelõng säilib paremini.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et siia tuli üks Event juurde. Mida see Location form ja miti funny.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd oleks vaja see ära ka dokumenteerida. Hetkel ta ütleb, et see A. Nüüd Me teame, et tegelikult tuli juurde üks Event
Õpetaja: Aa. Selle võib isegi võtta koos nendega massiivis. Kuidas eraldame objekte koma, aga näed, ma kogemata Sõin selle tagumise
Õpetaja: Ee, kasti ära. Niimoodi ei ole Puud on hoopis ee.
Õpetaja: Ee. Puudu oli hoopis ringi lõpetav tekst.
Õpetaja: Kui neid tuleb, palju, Siis need saab üksteise alla lüüa. Näiteks
Õpetaja: jälle. Ma sõin ära selle. Noh, niimoodi saab niimoodi ka teha lihtsam. Lugeda, on nii
Õpetaja: nüüd, on Jälle see, et läheb üks korrus kõrgemale.
Õpetaja: Kes on Location Formi pärand?
Õpetaja: Noh, see vist oli Location View.
Õpetaja: Siia on vaja samamoodi, teha, et Kuule, kui alt tuleb Nihukene Event. No seda osa saab klik siit võtta. Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: näiteks kuni siiamaani saab võtta, et. Ee, kui ma lähen Location View Sse.
Õpetaja: Siin on üks Event, on onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, tuled. Lööd uue rea. Ütled, et veel üks See vent?
Õpetaja: Oleksid komitsi ka Davai, Aga Kohe kui selle lõigu teeb lõpuni, siis.
Õpetaja: No mis? Ma Siia kirjutan? Kui alt tuleb Event number Ftm. Subdate, et mis meil soov on,
Õpetaja: nagu näeme nagu retsilt vaeva. Vaata aga, et see uueneks.
Õpetaja: Andro, mis see?
Õpetaja: Jah, täpi pealt. Nii ongi.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: See muster on ju tegelikult täpselt sama, onju? Jumala hea ongi hea. Me saame nagu näha, Location Form Komponent laetakse alla, antakse andmed
Õpetaja: alt tulevad sündmused vastu.
Õpetaja: Kõik. On koodis kirjas.
Õpetaja: Okei, labid, mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Checkboxid. Aa, okei. No nüüd saab nalja. Nüüd. Asjad ei ole nii lihtsad enam,
Õpetaja: sest et, ee, Nüüd on andmed. Ee, mis on on natukene keerukama vormiga, Kuna need on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil alla voolab. Nüüd. Peab jälle mõtlema. Võin kõik kinni panna alustada seda teekonda uuesti onju, et Location View on meil pärand. Tema on. Ma tõstan ta siiapoole ja nüüd siis on Transaction Type Checkbox. Meil järgmine tegelane, kelle ma tõstan siia vasakule, et
Õpetaja: Child Parent Grand Parent.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis meil siin On Esiteks, meil nüüd on See dünaamiline osa. Vaata, et kogu see tiv, mis meil siin on,
Õpetaja: et input E tehakse nii mitu nagu on. Vaja.
Õpetaja: Vaadake nüüd on Mure. Ee, selles.
Õpetaja: No jah, okei, ee. Me teeme seda natuke lihtsamalt, kui ma vanasti teinud. Aga ma pean lihtsalt ühe asja ära selgitama,
Õpetaja: Okei, no hakkame. Hakkame niukeste asjadega pihta. Mida me teame, on see, et, ee, mida meil on vaja ülesse tegelikult saata,
Õpetaja: kui see vaata See checkt on nüüd siin. Ee, all pool.
Õpetaja: Ma tõstaks ta natukene ülesse poole. Tõstaks ta siia
Õpetaja: silme all. Vaata, kui me vaatame Location View D ja neid ka. Vaata, on ju või? Vabandust, neid. Ee, input E. Siis see välju oli kohe seal suht nagu all Ma Korra vaatan üle kuidas meil. Ee, ta nagu oli. Oli. Vaata, välju on kohe Siin all on ju? Ja Mitt on üleval.
Õpetaja: Lihtne on näha.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi flirdin selle mõttega. Vaata, et ee, tõstaks need asetsused. Ära tõstaks selle ad value. Kohe ütleme niimoodi, kui me vajutame entrit,
Õpetaja: Nad on kõik eraldi rea peal. Nad on kõik selle input I sees. Näed, siit Kolmnurk algab. Siit lõppeb, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aa, mina tahaks Tõsta järjekorda natukene, et oleks kuidagi loogilisem. Props tuleb sisse. See on esimene asi, mida me tahame näha.
Õpetaja: Ja järgmine asi on see. Me Tahame näha, mida ta mit Ib. Sellepärast, et siis meil on nagu kuidagi lihtne jälgida neid kahte asja. Teeme seda samamoodi ka. Number of
Õpetaja: Ee, number of. Kuidas saab kiirelt? Noh, control Shift n number of Teeme siin samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Näed, siin tuleb vähemalt uuel, Real et tõstame niimoodi, et on nagu sellises järjekorras. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Natuke parem on niimoodi jälgida, et mida ma kõigepealt tahan näha. Ma tahan näha, et mis siia sisse tuleb ja siis ma tahan näha, mis välja läheb. Tüübid asjad värgid. Vaata, noh, need võiks ka kuidagi mingis üh ühtlases järjekorras olla, Kui me praegu sellele ei keskendu
Õpetaja: ise nagu enda jaoks, on nagu mõelda selgeks, et mis on tähtis, mis? Tüüpi asi see on on Suht tähtis kujundus Id Place Holder. Noh, need asjad ka, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga need kaks on, mis tegelikult ütleme, päris ausalt, kõige rohkem meile huvi pakuvad. Teeme nüüd seda. Trans Transaction. Sellega ka. Siia tuleb sisse eas. Available on ju
Õpetaja: transaction types Available True False siin. Me tahame samamoodi teha. Ät inpot, Klikk klikk, Klikk on tegelikult ikkagi inpot.
Õpetaja: Tahame jälle miittida.
Õpetaja: Ee, korra läheb, vaatab. Mina lihtsalt copy based saate kirjutada, et Ee, mõtleme välja, et mis me Paneme. Selle nimeks
Õpetaja: See keskmine osa peaks muutuma. Noh see on transaction.
Õpetaja: Transaction Type. Update Kohe Räägin teile.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, see on vee. See kogu. See kõik on four tsükliga tehtud. Tegelikult päris koodis on neid nagu kokku kolm korda on. Ju Me ei tahaks panna siin seda Event Transaction types. Sellepärast, kui ma teen kliki, siis ma teen seda. Ainult ühes konkreetses. Transaction Type is
Õpetaja: ühest Konkreetses checkboxist, onju? Et see võiks olla ainsuses.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mis me järgmisena teeme,
Õpetaja: on see.
Õpetaja: Ma teen nüüd seda esimest korda natuke teistmoodi. Me tegelikult. Peame Ma Räägin, mis see on.
Õpetaja: Aa, Long Game on see, et me läheme siis kaks korrust kõrgemale,
Õpetaja: kuni me jõuame Location View Sse ja meie plaan on muuta Ära niiöelda true befors ühel nendest objektidest
Õpetaja: ühel nendest objektidest, siis ee, seekord muutub natuke keerulisemaks, on, see et me peame tegelikult siis käima tsükliliselt läbi.
Õpetaja: Need olemasolevad niiöelda transaction Type Id
Õpetaja: leidma mingi pidepunkti abil. Just selle,
Õpetaja: kui ma toon näite, et vaata, siin on. Kui ma panin raha välja,
Õpetaja: siis kui vaadata näiteks ee, koodi ja võtame selle näite siin, mis siin all on,
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen raha välja, panen tiktpoksi. Panen sisse. Siis? Mis taustal peab andmetes juhtuma,
Õpetaja: Vastab tõele, et see peaks minema truuks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see et ainult ühel peab muutuma. See niiöelda
Õpetaja: ühel peab see muutuma. Siis see lahendus on selline. Vaata, et Me käime lihtsalt four tsükliga läbi neid.
Õpetaja: Ja mida me otsime?
Õpetaja: Vaata, see. Me teeme niimoodi, et meil on plaan, on see, et alt Me paneme põhimõtteliselt teele. Ta teeb ka enne koopia. Sellest on ju. Me paneme imitiga teele. Vaata, et saada üles kogu see objekt,
Õpetaja: Aga siis on nagu see, et Vaata, me peame leidma ülesse. Niiöelda selle õige objekti.
Õpetaja: Childis ei tohi asju muuta. Vaata, see on see või Vabandust, Childis Props väärtus ei tohi muutuda. Me peame ülevalt mõjutama. Siis on see, et me meie target. On. See siis meie eesmärk ongi. Me kujutamegi ette, Vaata, et Meil, on see info. Ma panen siia korra kõrvale.
Õpetaja: See info tuleb meile põhimõtteliselt niiöelda ee pakiga
Õpetaja: Ja meie missioon on siis käia läbi.
Õpetaja: Leida just see objekt, mis tegelikult vastab siis
Õpetaja: sellele objektile, mille abil me seda saame teha?
Õpetaja: Taipidi, sest nad on unikaalsed
Õpetaja: Ja siis me Peame tegema niimoodi, et mis iganes on siin see väärtus on, see vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Me peame muutma ära selle oma target objektis.
Õpetaja: Kas saate aru, mis see plaan on?
Õpetaja: Sest et ainult üks peab neist muutuma.
Õpetaja: Nii, mida me ei saa teha, on see, et me seda chilis Muudame Seda me ei saa.
Õpetaja: Me võime korra proovida. Ma ei tea, see tundub natuke kuidagi kahtlane, et
Õpetaja: vaata päeva lõpuks. Tegelikult, kui me saame. Vaata, siin on nagu. See on hästi natuke teil raske aru saada, aga ma proovin seda selgitada.
Õpetaja: Tehniliselt võttes, mis ma olen rääkinud mälust ja ee mäluviidetest kasutada, siis.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on mõttes. Aga mõte on see, et meil taustal on objektid ja meil on viited nendele,
Õpetaja: Kui meie anname kogu selle massiivi niiöelda alla, on ju siis tehniliselt võttes tegelikult juba algusest peale meie kuskil mälukohas on Aa, see objekt sellisel kujul olemas.
Õpetaja: Ja ütleme nii, et et kui see Propside kaudu hakkab alla voolama, siis seal on ma arvan, sama mõte, et antakse Mingit mäluviidet üle, mitte objekti. Kui füüsilist Sellist asja ennast onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui meie jõuame sinna valikute juurde, on ju? Ja nüüd klikime ühte Event I. Kui meie ütleme niimoodi, et Kuule, ole hea, saada see objekt ülesse, siis tegelikult jälle antakse ainult ülevaate. Selle objekti viide.
Õpetaja: See tuleb Meile tegelikult ülesse. Ja see siis on meil lihtsalt nagu kaks muutujat, et ühtepidi on See objekt olemas. Location i küljes transaction type all on see objekt olemas
Õpetaja: ja teistpidi. See tuleb meile ülesse. Sinna Aa, Barentysse. Meil on see objekt olemas ja me võime öelda, ka, et Event kujul on. Meil. Viide sellele objektile. Meil on tegelikult mitu muutujat, mis viitavad sellele samale
Õpetaja: objektile.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma ei tea, vanasti ma nii tegin. Vaata kindluse huvides. Minu meelest hakkas teistpidi vinguma. Oli see, et ma läksin siis niimoodi, et selle asemel, et kuidagi hakata üleval Mudima
Õpetaja: seda sama objekti. Vaata ja öelda, et pane siin see muutus üheks või Teiseks. On ju.
Õpetaja: Aa, Ma juba näen. Siin on probleem, me Ei, saa objekti saata. Fuck, Mul läheb koguaeg meelest ära. See on põhjus, miks ma olen alati nii. Teinud.
Õpetaja: Mõtleme korra, kujutame ette, et See, on praegu Childis ja Seal Checkboxil.
Õpetaja: Kui Mina vajutan. Ee, niiöelda checkti.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen seda tärni input käivitub Event iga saadaksime selle objekti ülesse,
Õpetaja: Siis minu küsimus on see, mis on hetkel selle objekti väärtus pools.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et sa saadad lihtsalt selle objekti üle. Ma ei tea tegelikult, Kas nüüd see peaks olema? Ma saaks teha niukse loogika, et ma vahetan üleval selle dogliga Ära vaata, et nagu, et, noh, Pane lihtsalt tagurpidi. Võta see sisu ja anna talle lihtsalt tagurpidine väärtus.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on üks moodus.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei kujuta ette, kuidas asjad Siis hakkaksid toimima, kui võibolla. Hästi, kiired klikid edasi tagasi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen selle niimoodi, vaata, et tegelikult saada ülesse väärtus sellest Id St. Ja sellest väärtusest, Mis sellest kastist endast võetakse, siis vähemalt sellel hetkel. Kui see sõnum läheb, siis ta kindlasti paneb selle õige väärtuse
Õpetaja: et Ta võtab selle input i pealt, Saate aru. Siin on nagu see mure. Vaata, me võime korra proovida. Mis juhtub ja ma pole kunagi seda niipidi teinud. Proovime korra niimoodi nagu ma ei ole varem seda teinud. Ja vaatame, et ma arvan, et ei tee järgi, ta töötab,
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et tal mingit probleemi ei tule ja siis korra arutleme. Kas seda võib olla teha vanaviisi või mitte, Võibolla hakkab üldse kisama ka, et talle ei meeldi see, mis? Ma tahan teha temaga nii.
Õpetaja: Mida ma kindlalt tean, on see, et ma ei tohi seda Childist teha, aga ma ei ole mitte kunagi proovinud teha ühte asja, mida ma praegu tahan mõttes teha Parentes.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma räägin, mis ma mõte on? Näe, ma ütlen niimoodi, mida ei tohi teha. Ma alustan sellest. Võtame selle Transaction Type Checkboxi välja. Kui mina teeksin näiteks siia praegult Aa, ühe meetodi.
Õpetaja: Sest et ma ei oskaks seda kuidagi teha. Tege ma korra mõtlen praegu. Ma ei oskaks seda siit otse koodi realt teha, et ma tahaks öelda, et võta konkreetne kõnealune objekt. No, kes on transaction Type
Õpetaja: is available. Ahah, Okei, saaks küll. True False
Õpetaja: hetkel Kujutame ette, et ma olen. Me peame kuidagi visualiseerima. Ka
Õpetaja: Ee, hetkel, kui ma ma tulen,
Õpetaja: on ee. Tühi on ju Oletan, ma klikin seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, hetkel. See on niiöelda tühi ja ta on peal. Andmed voolavad praegult sisse, et kujutame. No teeme veel lihtsamalt. See on see Esimene kast. Esimene luup
Õpetaja: luupimisega on alati niimoodi. Kui koodi kirjutad. Lihtsalt mõtle esimese tsükli peale. Mida sa tahad teha ja ongi kõik
Õpetaja: loogika, Mis sa paned paika? Kehtib ju kõikidele. On ju hetkel. Ta on tühi. No paneme ta kõrvale, et oleks ee. Võimalik vaadata. Ee teeme koodi niimoodi korra. See on mõtlemine. See ei ole praegu kaasategemise koht.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen, vajutan input Il niiöelda nuppu. Click. Siis ee. Oota. On ikka õige asi. Paneme teistest kinni,
Õpetaja: Kui mina klikin selle peale input käivitub, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin praegult kirjutada, et võta see transaction Type.
Õpetaja: Mida me siin niiöelda googeldame? Ütlen, et tema alamobjekt is available
Õpetaja: ja nüüd ütlen et sina, saa uus väärtus
Õpetaja: ja ma saan öelda, et võta. Mis iganes ongi selle väärtus. Aga pane tagurpidi. Kuidas see süntaks võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Hüüumärk ja panen selle sama. Vaata, et see on Iseendale väärtuse andmine.
Õpetaja: Hei, sest et vaata, kuidas kood töötab. Ta ei vaata seda vasakut poolt enne me koodi kirjutame ja mõtleme nii, kui on mistahes Ee, nagu see võrdusmärk. Või return, siis alati parem. Pool rehkendatakse ennem ja siis minnakse vasaku poole kallale.
Õpetaja: Siin on see, et Võta see väärtus. Mis iganes on.
Õpetaja: Kui see on False, siis see teeb ta praegult kokku truuks.
Õpetaja: Kui ta oleks olnud truu, siis see teeb False iks
Õpetaja: siin. Ta paneb selle lihtsalt tagurpidi. Ja nüüd ütleme, et Anna uus väärtus.
Õpetaja: Aga mis nüüd on halvasti, on see? Vaata, et See tegelikult see Transaction Type on osa sellest. Props ist on nii,
Õpetaja: et nüüd see muutus Tegelikult ju programmeerimise mõttes mõttes toimib
Õpetaja: ei Ole sellepärast, et see tegelikult on. Kujuta ette see praegult, kui kood genereerib ja ma vajutan, ma vajutan ainult ühte Nendest see ei toimu, Kõigil aga probleem on see, et me hakkame natuke, nagu hakkame tegema. Props ei tohi olla
Õpetaja: ühegi elemendiga, mis muudaks tema väärtust. Aga nüüd Me programmiliselt muudame tema väärtust. Kus kohas see pro? Kus kohas on see kood? Kirjutatud
Õpetaja: lapses. Me anname uue väärtuse. Ma arvan, et see ei ole, okei. Me võime
Õpetaja: Nupi sees ei ole aju. Kas see nupi sees ei ole kohalik?
Õpetaja: Ei ole kohalik muutuja. Tähendab, vahet pole, Me ei tohi objekti muuta
Õpetaja: no oota, siin on hästi Natukene hall ala. Vaata, et see ei ole otseselt transaction types, mida me üle Kirjutame vaid transaction Typesi sees on objekt, aga ärme unusta. Vaata, see on reaktiivne asi. Kas me siin oleme mingi ette andnud? Talle
Õpetaja: ma tegelt oleme. Vaata, et kui Type Id muutub, onju, et siis midagi peab uuesti renderdama. Kuidas ta siis üldse teab, et uuesti renderdada, sest et see Type Id ei muutu. Vaatame seda asja. Igal juhul ma praegult. Ma nagu arvan, et see tegelikult ei tohiks olla okei,
Õpetaja: sest Ma annan Propsi ühele osale. Mis kuradi loll küsimus? Aa, ma küsin parem. Ee, ma küsin. Kas selline asi on Okei,
Õpetaja: Ee, me ei taha uut Cloud I lahti teha. Vana instants on juba natukene Chat inad.
Õpetaja: Ee, tal on rohkem konteksti. Ma teen nüüd niukest trikki, Vaata et ma lootsin, et ma saan selle reanumbri siia endale kenasti,
Õpetaja: on ju Aga ta. Ei tee seda. Siis ta tegi uue akna, lahti Avas sellest, Cloud I. Kui nüüd võtta uuesti see sama rida ja öelda Control K
Õpetaja: siia ka ei saa jah, No enam üldse ei taha töötada. No mine sa ka. Ee, siis ma teen juba niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Cancel Cancell. Ei, selle paneme kinni terminate.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, mis ta vahel niimoodi teeb.
Õpetaja: Kas tõesti ei saa? Nagu või vanasti ta töötasin. Vahet pole. Ma panen selle ka praegu kinni. Ma. Ma seekord teen niimoodi käsitsi. Ma ütlen Copy Bath Reference. Räägin sellest failist.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin, et kas selline asi on okei?
Õpetaja: Mul on selline lähenemine,
Õpetaja: sest et Ma ei ole nagu kindel, sest mu sisetunne ütleb, et see ei ole okei, et Prox I objekti alam osa objekti muuta anda uut väärtust. Childis tundub väga väga sus.
Õpetaja: Aga mine sa tea, äkki kui ainult osaliselt, nagu seda muudan. Ee, muidu iseenesest oleks hästi lihtne see Siis No vaatame. Ma annan selle koodilõivudele kätte.
Õpetaja: Selline lähenemine. Ma panen talle näiteks sulud siia ja panen selle koodilõigu ja ütlen, küsin, kas See on okei, Mis see tunne ütleb, et ei ole? Okei,
Õpetaja: aga võibolla ma eksin. Võibolla ma. Ei, ma ei, ma ütlen. Ma ei, tea, See on nagu. See on juba hästi peensus. Vaata, tehnoloogia. Peensuste tundmine
Õpetaja: lühidalt töötab aga rikub uue andme poolt. Põhimõtted, props alla, sündmused ülesse, kui transaction types. Mis on meie props? Vaata, mille pealt need andmed ju tulevad. Mis? Sest, et ta tuleb siin?
Õpetaja: Variaktiivne objekt Barentis Võib muutus küll levida, aga see on juhuslik käitumine, mitte. Disain,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult ikkagi nii ei tohi teha.
Õpetaja: No aga nüüd ma küsin natukene, Jah, okei, Aa. Ma küsin talt nüüd teistmoodi, Aga kui ma annaksin kogu
Õpetaja: selle
Õpetaja: konkreetse ee, objekti ülesse barentile
Õpetaja: ja siis seal otse muudaks Konkreetselt
Õpetaja: sama objekti väärtust.
Õpetaja: Nii kate tagurpidi.
Õpetaja: Kas see oleks ok?
Õpetaja: Siis ma panen nüüd alternatiiv. Alternatiiv oleks käia läbi selle massiivi objektid, variantis Ja muuta konkreetse.
Õpetaja: Ee, konkreetse objekti väärtust.
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma. Mind. Su kõnetab rohkem. Mida ma nagu Mõtlen. Ma ei tea, kuidas tema mõtleb, seda kohe saab teada.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan näha, mis ta ütleb selle kohta, sest et siin on natukene abstraktsiooni, et siin, on Ma tahan teha midagi,
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis ta räägib. Mõlemad variandid olid on tegelikult sama probleem. Objektid on järgi, millest ma olen rääkinud mäluvide,
Õpetaja: kuid Zaild emiteerib tervet Transaction Type I objekti ülesse,
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Pärend saab kätte. Sama objekti viite. See on mälus. Täpselt sama objekt, mis Propsis
Õpetaja: kui pärand teeb, et muuda ära see pane tagurpidiseks. Siis muudab pärand. Tegelikult samu mälu. Mäluaadressi objekti. Mida sai,
Õpetaja: Ee, tulemus on identne otsese propi muteerumisega lihtsalt ühe vaheetapi kaudu. Õige lähenemine, et emiteerib ainult Id. Pärand täidab selle objekti ise üles ja asendab uuega Ühesõnaga ta ikkagi mõtles Nii nagu mina mõtlesin.
Õpetaja: Ee, tema Mõtleb. Vaata, onju. Ma korra küsin nagu esimese otsa veel otsa ka talt, onju Ta tegelikult ütleb, et Kas see nagu hookus pookus, mis ma tahtsin teha, ei ole ka ikkagi päris okei? Sest et me peame mõtlema nendest siinkuju objektidest,
Õpetaja: sa ei tohi seda objekti niimoodi. Sa sa. Ei. Sa. Nagu sa võid töötada. Vaata mingi valemiga, et sa tegelikult nagu. See pole päris õige, Ma küsin viimase küsimuse. Vaata, et, ee.
Õpetaja: Kas ma peaksin minna Ee pärendile kaasa andma? Mõlemad
Õpetaja: mõlemad nii Id kui ka
Õpetaja: väärtuse või piisab Ainult Ee. Dougle. Ei, vabandust, Id väärtusest.
Õpetaja: Ja teeb dogle lahenduse. Dogle Dogel on nupp sisse. Välja üks või teine, kaks täitja,
Õpetaja: sest ma Ise olen alati andnud ikkagi päris selle väärtuse kaasa, mis ma olen saanud.
Õpetaja: Okei, siis läheb väheke lihtsamalt.
Õpetaja: Siis Nii teeme Davai, ma sain nagu kätte. Vaata, ta ütleb, et see on piisavalt turvaline. Tuleme nüüd selle lõpuks tagasi.
Õpetaja: Me teeme täpselt seda, mida ta ütles, põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: meil Lihtsalt on vaja Id D,
Õpetaja: et kelle väärtus peab muutuma vastupidiseks.
Õpetaja: Ja me peame selle muutma ära. Aga me peame seda muutma Pärendis, Me Peame leidma üles õige objekti ja muutma ära tema väärtuse. Vot nii on korrektne.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis teeme siit.
Õpetaja: See on Mingi Dollari märk. Puhdalt Ringub vist vä,
Õpetaja: Nii et. Ee. Jällegi. Mul on meelest ära läinud. Kas ta kellelgi on veel ees? Mis me vendi nimeks enne panime?
Õpetaja: Kas update? Jah, nii kaasame. Nüüd paneme Aa tõesti siis ainult sellest. Transaction Type ist. Tema Id.
Õpetaja: Nii Ütleme niimoodi. Näed, me ei anna tervet objekti kaasa. Me ei anna Transaction Type I kaasa. Vabandust, siin on kõigepealt Jah, et me ei hakka ka tegema seda, et me Võtame kaasa tema check väärtuse Vaid me eeldame seda, et meil on juba praegu sünkroonis. Vaata, onju, et mis check väärtus on Hetkel see, Mis alla tuli
Õpetaja: Nüüd me lihtsalt läheme ülesse. Muudame ära
Õpetaja: tema flob alla tagasi ja siis see visuaalselt muutub. Ja data on ka korrektselt, Nii et see on nagu ideaalne, et et seda teostust ära, teha, siis tema pakkus ka, et tegelikult piisab täiesti sellest Id St on
Õpetaja: Nii, kus ma siis nüüd olen? Kus see Mitt? On, Siin,
Õpetaja: Ee, saadame kaasa mingi Id Ahaa,
Õpetaja: ee. Ta lähebki numbrina, sest et projekt ta juba siin. Transaction Type Transaction. Type Id. Ongi juba number. No siis ongi niimoodi. Lihtsalt kirjutame Transaction. Type
Õpetaja: Punkt
Õpetaja: Tti.
Õpetaja: Ei, ta ei oska. Aa, no tuli või Transaction Type Id. Pakiga läheb Id kaasa. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Nii, ee. Okei, nõus.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil see üks korrus lahendatud. Nüüd on. Järgmine on location form.
Õpetaja: Siit võib juba copida selle Event I nime.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin on see element. Alla voolab Selline asi.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mitu reavahetust. Panen selle siia siia. Paneb ä juba ära, enne kui unustab ja ütleb, et juhul kui
Õpetaja: Niukene Event tuleb, siis mis me teeme. Viskame ainult paki edasi.
Õpetaja: No võib korra rottida siit selle
Õpetaja: sisu, et anname kogu sisu üle üles, edasi,
Õpetaja: aga kuna ma Copy Based Isin, Siit siis see Event Nimi, mis ülesse jõuab, on vale. Vaid Nüüd Copy Based ina. Muudan asemele.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt alt tuleb Event viska edasi. Võibolla vahepeal. I Love Optimizing. Kui mingid tühikud või asjad on siin kuidagi paikast ära läinud
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: nii ülesse läheb Tegelikult me teame Ainult Transaction Type Id, Onju, et paki sees on,
Õpetaja: mille peale klikkisime? Tema Id.
Õpetaja: Me ei näe seda. Vaata, me ei näe siit neid Id Sid.
Õpetaja: Kui ei usu, siin on see ka. Vaata, kui ma korraks võiks seda peale panna, et kui ma võtan Need Transaction type Checkboxid, kus nad on? Näete seda label It
Õpetaja: Levelil on hetkel ainult transaction name, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma. Panen korra siia juurde, lihtsalt tuimalt juurde, et on ka transaction Type Id. Sa ärge teie tehke Seda ma lihtsalt näitan. Las olla numbrid. Taga
Õpetaja: Need numbrid on olemas selle Transaction Type objekti küljes.
Õpetaja: Transaction type, transaction. Type Id näitab. Näed ja meie saadamegi mit iga selle ülesse. Näed, just selline asi läheb ülesse. Nii, las ta praegu olla on. Pärast ma tulen võtan selle siit ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd sellest vormist. Me saime selle miti kätte. No siis on meil põhimõtteliselt vaja kogu seda sama kamarajura uuesti. Korra võib korra selle terve selle rea võtta. Lihtsalt teeme seekord nii. Nüüd lähme otsime oma Ülesse. Meie
Õpetaja: Control shift n location ulv. Siit valib õige asja.
Õpetaja: No location formil on järjest need Event Id siin on niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nii nüüd Seekord me ei taha siis. Aa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis tõesti vaja. Ee, natukene rohkem hookus fookust teha ja me ei suuda inline selle sama Ee, niiöelda line i peal. Me ei suuda seda lahendust ära kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, tema pakkus ka. Ma pakkus ka mingi midagi taolist. Korra Vaatan, Mis ta pakkus selle nimeks
Õpetaja: Tee Meetod. Ei, see mulle ei meeldiks.
Õpetaja: Paneks Handle. Mulle meeldib Handle.
Õpetaja: Me kirjutame meetodid, mida pole veel Transacks Action Taipe
Õpetaja: update. Paneme siis update.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd see on niimoodi, et me võiksime panna need sulud. Aga me ei, pane seda. Te saate ette kujutada, et
Õpetaja: vaikimisi see kood töötaks niimoodi. Nagu me lahti kirjutame, et alt tuli mingi event. Mis me teame, on lihtsalt transaction Type Id, onju? Mis tuli nagu pakina, et käivita siin meie meetodi Blokis Handle Transaction Type Update meetod
Õpetaja: ja kaasa läheb see pakk aga ta teeb seda juba Out of the Box, et meil ei ole vaja seda niimoodi teha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me läheme. Me kopime selle nime
Õpetaja: ja nüüd Me läheme, teeme blokki sama nimelise meetodi.
Õpetaja: Aga niimoodi, et ta võtab sisse parameetrina
Õpetaja: ühe väärtuse. Kuhu see pakk automaatselt kukub? Ja Selle muutuja nimi peab sümboliseerima. Mis pakina teele läks? Ehk siis
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Id. See meil tuleb pakina. Ja kui me tuleme, võtame selle meetodi,
Õpetaja: tulen Otsin Methods bloki. No ma panen ta siia ülesse. Praegult niimoodi. Panen selle sama nime. Panen sulud. Vaitan. Control Shift Enter.
Õpetaja: Teen juba selle Keha valmis ja alt see event iga käivitatakse. Vaadake, Event
Õpetaja: Transaction Type Update käivitab selle meetodi. Vaikimisi pannakse kaasa pakikene.
Õpetaja: Minul on vaja ainult mingit muutuja nime mõelda. Välja. Mina võtaks selle muutuja nimeks Transaction Type Id.
Õpetaja: Mm Ee, Ma tahaksin. Ee.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaksin minna tegelikult kolm korrust alla ja ma tahaks seda Event i nime natukene muuta.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldib see Update siis, kui see, väärtus tuleks alt kaasa ja me update Ime,
Õpetaja: aga tegelikult ei tule väärtus kaasa. Vaid Tuleb ainult Id kaasa Ja tehakse selline asi nagu Dougle. Keera nupp. Tagurpidi. Teate nupp on, On Kurat, ee. Kas leiab kiirelt midagi? Ee, dogle.
Õpetaja: Vot on.
Õpetaja: No on ka. Aga ma ei, tea Mille all ta võiks olla.
Õpetaja: Checked Äkki checkt Checks all on Ee,
Õpetaja: checks.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt hoidsin ühte Switch switch.
Õpetaja: No vot, vot vot. Näete seda,
Õpetaja: Saate aru, Check, Vaata, onju sees väljast sees, väljas, sees väljas. Ta on ka põhimõtteliselt see sama. Vaata, onju, et kutsutaksegi seda. Vaata kui sa nuppu flipid ühest suunast teise, et selles selles tegevuses. Vaata, et, ee, selles tegevuses, et lülita numbr. Ee, lülita nupp tagurpidi. Teate seda nuppu
Õpetaja: nii ja niipidi, kuidas Kes tahab. Muidugi see on. See on, ee. See on tegelikult tavaline Check. Vaata, millel on lihtsalt Css. Näete, Form Switch on selle asja nimi.
Õpetaja: Väikene hookus pookus ja kohe juba muutub.
Õpetaja: Mis mitte võib. Nii ka
Õpetaja: ongi väga ilusam. Ee, aga mi see mu mõte on? Selle Nupuga on see, et Vaata, kui sa ütlesid, vaata, on nagu, et, ee nagu, ee, See on see nagu et muuda. Muuda nuppu nagu Vaata Muuda nuppu positsiooni või see Eesti keeles. Ma ei tea, kuidas see võiks olla. Vajuta,
Õpetaja: sa ei ütle suunda. Sa ei ütle, et Vajuta sisse. Sa Ei, ütle ta välja, vaid sa ütled, et lülita ümber lülite nuppi ümber, kui ta on niipidi.
Õpetaja: Tal on niipidi, nii et ma mõtlen, et see Event tegelikult võiks natukene olla parema nimega
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see meetod mida me käivitame ja tahaks ka kasutada seda Sama sõna
Õpetaja: siis me läheme tagasi siia. Aa, kus me seda saatsime ja hakkame vaatama neid Event e korra.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me teeme väiksed parandused Ka sellepärast, et. Ee, me muutsime seda. Siin on ju Siis me läheme ühe korruse kõrgemale. Muudame seda. Siin
Õpetaja: tuli ka meelde seda et alla ei lisanudki Onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee, võtaks kogu selle asja koos jutu Ee, märkidega ja lisaks siia ka peale koma.
Õpetaja: Vaata, nad lähevad kõik nüüd kenasti ühele reale, sest nad on nii kaugele juba surutud.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siia meie vanemasse. Me peame ka panema selle sama.
Õpetaja: Noh, kus See on nüüd see location ju siin ta on, onju?
Õpetaja: Vot nii
Õpetaja: see meetod, mis meil on juba valmis. Selle me refaktoreerime ümber. Vaata, et me ei taha sõna kasutada. Update
Õpetaja: Handle Transaction Type Dougle.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siis Kas teil Switch oleks kuidagi rohkem kõnetanud, vä?
Õpetaja: Mina tean seda Dougle vaatama.
Õpetaja: Ee, refaktor.
Õpetaja: Ee küsis kinnitust. Ma ütlesin ka
Õpetaja: Ee Davai
Õpetaja: Natukene Verifaktoreerime veel.
Õpetaja: Bundle Transaction Type Checkbox Dougle.
Õpetaja: Sa vist ei jõudnud teha veel seda. Võibolla
Õpetaja: ainult
Õpetaja: siin on isegi koht, kus ma mõtlen, et, ee. Võtame selle teksti. Teeme nüüd selle, et seda on igal Pool Control Shift ja R
Õpetaja: üle projekti otsija Replace.
Õpetaja: Et ta leiab kolmes neljas kohas. Seda on ju viies kohas igal pool, kus me Ära muudame. Ongi, Nagu
Õpetaja: Ahah. Ühes kohas on veel valesti. Vaata, näete, minul on location. Fornis on kuulaja. On Valesti. Näete pugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, teil on ka niimoodi. Vä
Õpetaja: See peaks ka siin helendama.
Õpetaja: Ma isegi teeks selle enne korda, kui ma seda hakkaks seda Replace tegema, et ma Muutsin siin ära. Vot seda ei olekski pidanud muutma käsitsi.
Õpetaja: Sa tahaks pead niimoodi et otsi üle projekti No see on nii unikaalne nagu Tekst onju,
Õpetaja: et seda oleks pidanud kõik korraga muutma igal pool, Sest et nüüd kogemata siin jäi see tegemata.
Õpetaja: Võib korra otsida seda seda vana asja veel. Korda. Control Shift F. Kas sa leiad projektist Ainult ühest kohast? See sama koht. Ehk siis
Õpetaja: selle asja muudame selliseks. Ma Teen kohe varsti komiiti ka. Kes ee, praegu tahab alla anda. On Fine
Õpetaja: nüüd seda vana asja ma võin panna. Control Shift F ja otsida Vana asja. Ta ei leia kuskilt üle projekti. Aga minu plaan on kust iganes kohas. Te selekteerite, aga mitte ätiga. Ee, nagu see Koht võib olla ätiga, aga mitte sisse. Ma tahaks Control Shift R nagu üle projekti Muuta selle väärtus ja tulla siia, seda võiks siit kopida, et oleks põhiees.
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks seda Event Transaction type tšekk, boks Dougelt ja pane. Replace. So lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Miks ta seda ei highlight, I Ahah,
Õpetaja: sest siin pole checkboxi Aga seda ma ju otsin. Ja mis on selle vahe? Ja selle vahe? Ma ei saa aru.
Õpetaja: Aa, ta näitab niimoodi erinevalt. Okei, Davai Replace Soul. Igaljuhul läheb,
Õpetaja: küsib, et oled kindel ja ja üle projekti muuda. Ära
Õpetaja: No nüüd, jah, okei, ta näitas seda sama asja kaks korda. Nüüd ma saan aru.
Õpetaja: Nii, Fine. Nüüd see peaks olema niimoodi. Ma tahtsin niimoodi, et need asjad nagu räägivad minuga. Event Transaction Type Checkbox. Dougle Saate. Aru, et nad nagu räägiksid omavahel kokku.
Õpetaja: Nii nüüd alt tuleb tõesti. Transaction peab tulema. Nüüd, Mul on see nagu, et. No mina seda meetodit ma ei hakka tegema. Me laseme selle meetodi implementatsiooni teha. Ära Chat Il,
Õpetaja: sellepärast et siin Tegelikult, kui mina oskaks oma oskustega teha, ma teeksin siin üks haaval, hakkaks vaatama Source ja Target ja vaataks nagu, et kuni ma Leian õige asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult on olemas selle jaoks niuksed map Meetodid, mis nagu käivad mingisuguse massiivi läbi näevad mingisugust vastet ja muudavad. Ma lihtsalt ei oska seda süntaksit. Ja see on nii tehniline. Ma ei tea, ei taha. Ehk siis ma mõtleksin talle niimoodi, et Ole hea
Õpetaja: Ikka, Ma ei saa seda siit niimoodi, aga ta vist tegelikult saab aru. Vaata, mul on Niuke tunne, et Connection on olemas Id ka Ennem ta kogu aeg. Vaata, Selected Five Lines ja nii edasi. Ee, ma ütlen talle. Ee, ma teen selle lahenduse ära ja siis teeme Väikse pausi ka äkki onju sobib?
Õpetaja: Ma teen selle lahenduse ära. Vaatame, et kas ta toimib.
Õpetaja: Siis liigume edasi. Ee, ma ütlen, et ee, Palun implementeeri Oh, kurat,
Õpetaja: klikk siia. Vot see on natuke tüütu. Seal terminaliga hullult pead jälgima. Ma olen kogu aeg seda teinud. Kogemata tikk on kuskil koodi Selles kirjutad mingi teksti, siis vaatad. Oh, siin on mingi punane. Kõik
Õpetaja: nii. Ee. Implementeeri see lekted.
Õpetaja: Kuna see vestlus oli meil täpselt see sama, millest me rääkisime. Siis ta peaks olema.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi nüüd selle lahenduse ära. Nüüd me võime seda vaadata, mis ta teeb. Ta Esiteks ütleb, et. Ee. See massiiv.
Õpetaja: Saa sina uus sisu. Ta teeb täiesti uue objekti.
Õpetaja: Ta Käib läbi Aa, Kõik Transaction Type Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Map. Iga ta ütleb, et iga kord võta üks Taip. Näete, kas see on tuttav? Natuke see asi siin,
Õpetaja: see siin on Lihtsalt Muutuja nimi.
Õpetaja: See siin on Action kus me oleme seda varem näinud
Õpetaja: Ja onju? Ja siin ta ütleb, et vaata, et kui sa Vaata seda objekti. T,
Õpetaja: võta üks objekt sealt. Vaata sealt Transaction.
Õpetaja: Kui see võrdub sellega, mis siia meil. Ee, niiöelda pakina sisse tuleb.
Õpetaja: See. Nüüd on siin Short Hand. See tähendab, see on Niukene süntaks.
Õpetaja: Siin on kolm osapoolt.
Õpetaja: Siin on võrdlus, mis peab rehkenduma tõena. Väär
Õpetaja: siis on? Mis saab olema selle tee Uus sisu.
Õpetaja: Ma seda ei oska natuke selgitada, et see küsimärgi ja kooloni vahel on see, et mis sa. Mis peab juhtuma siis, kui on tõene
Õpetaja: ja viimane on see, mis siis on, kui väär? Meil vahet pole, see on nii keeruline süntaks. Ma ütlen seda saakski lihtsamalt teha. Ma võin öelda, et kas sa saaksid teha mulle mingi more Beginner Friendly, aga, Tegelikult, noh, päris Elus, oleks see läbi selle map. Vaata, see, et mina kahjuks ei tunne. Nagu seda süntaksit ei tähenda seda, et ei peaks seda kasutama, Onju,
Õpetaja: et tulevad asjad ka. Aa, Ma ei teagi üle öelda et. Ee. Mingi Friendly.
Õpetaja: Tahate niimoodi?
Õpetaja: Huvi pärast? Ma vaatan.
Õpetaja: No Davai. Ee, Anna jälle. Anna, vaatame.
Õpetaja: Ee, Anna mulle rohkem Beginner.
Õpetaja: Noh, paneme Super Beginner.
Õpetaja: Friendly läheb. Muidugi läheb pikemaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, versioon.
Õpetaja: Mida Oskan kah äkki lugeda, sest alab umbes nii halvasti. Muidugi nüüd lugeda ja aru saada.
Õpetaja: Muudkui kõmmutab. Aga nüüd järsku on nagu mingi kuul koos ee, tuleb mingi map ette Ja ma tean suures pildis kuidas see töötab.
Õpetaja: Natukene parema. No vaatame. Aa, mapsis käib läbi kõiki. Aa, neid objekte, mis tal siin ees on? Ehk see on originaalmassiiv. Nüüd ütleb, et hakkame neid ekseldama läbi. Loon sulle niimoodi, et igal igal korral võtan ühe objekti selle asja. Seest
Õpetaja: voon, uue muutuja Action läheb pihta ja siis tema vaatab, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: kas see üksikobjekt ja tema Transaction Type Id? Noh, see number üks ja kaks ja kolm võrdub sellega, mis tuli sisse.
Õpetaja: Kui jah, siis. No vot, see on mingisugune asi, mida väga ei tea, siis ta põhimõtteliselt ütleb, et lükka ka enda massiivi. Üks uus objekt. Kus?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma. Ma ütlesin, et lihtne kood sõber.
Õpetaja: Paneme Ilma mapita.
Õpetaja: No ma nii ei öelnud. Tegelikult võiks öelda. Sa ei öelnud nii.
Õpetaja: Oota, mis Ta ütleb ka midagi. Ta lihtsalt teeb koodi Ära
Õpetaja: ikka mingi for luubiga. Lihtsalt seda voortsükkel.
Õpetaja: Näete? Four tsüklit? Ikka? Teate, paremal pool on kollektsioon.
Õpetaja: Vaata, siin on See off. On sõna Lihtsalt selle in asemel
Õpetaja: võta. Käi läbi. See niiöelda asi. Need algväärtused,
Õpetaja: loo, üks sildikene. Ja nüüd ta vaatab seda seda asja ja siis seda ühte objekti korraga, et võta siit. Aa, objektist. Eno Raud. Vaata tema nime. Kas see kattub selle nimega, mis sisse tuli? Või Jah, siis selle sama objekti väärtus
Õpetaja: is. Available pane, mis juba on Aga tagurpidi? Noh, see on juba.
Õpetaja: See on juba varem, See on see sama. Vaadake seda videot. See sama koodiga.
Õpetaja: Eno raud, Eno Raud.
Õpetaja: Siin on kõik. Ee, te niiöelda tegelased.
Õpetaja: Siin on Eno Raud. Eno Rauaga. Vaatame midagi. Kas nimi on. See Kui jah, siis muuda midagi seal objektis. Ma ei tea sünniaasta midagi ära. Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: See on juba Tavaline, See on parem tänud.
Õpetaja: Pool luuk käib massiivi läbi, leiab õige objekt ja muudab selle väärtuse ära Märkus See muteerib objekti otse, mida Eelnevalt arutasime. Pole ideaalne,
Õpetaja: aga vea voeraktiivsus märkab siiski, et praktikas töötab.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas teist aa Okei teistmoodi ta tegi teate, kuidas vä.
Õpetaja: See Teine lahendus, mis ta algselt pakkuda oli See Nüüd Ma saan taustal aru, et ta teeb tegelikult taustal valmis uue messi.
Õpetaja: Need objektid, mis Muudatust ei ole vaja. Ja täpselt sellised nagu sellest lähteandmetest võetakse. Ja ainult ühel muudetakse väärtus ära. Ja lõpus öeldakse, et sul on uus Sisu. See on nagu õige
Õpetaja: Siis tegelikult peaks ütlema, talle, et siis ma peaks talle ütlema.
Õpetaja: Jah, Davai. Tee siis ikka nii, nagu enam Oli
Õpetaja: nii lihtne kui võimalik. Printsiipe järgi.
Õpetaja: Meil on toides ikka nii, nagu enne oli Lähme edasi ja lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, ee, et ta. Ta. Ma saan nagu, vahest aru. Ta teeb täiesti uue massiivi nagu eelmise koopia
Õpetaja: ja ühel lihtsalt muudab väärtuse ära ja seal on See, et vaata, seal on ikkagi see. Vaata, see lahendus tõesti. Ikka Ilmselt mitte midagi. Ei muutu, et me katsume seda esialgset niiöelda objekti Lihtsalt ja muteerume teda. Aga tegelikult peaks talle tulema lihtsalt uus objekt. Nagu sisse uus väärtus Ja siis andmed flow uvad täiesti uuesti. Alla
Õpetaja: See on niuke. Hästi, niisugune peenem. Peened, peened, nüansid. Aga me tegelt ei peagi rohkem midagi teadma. Nii oleme rahul, sellega on ju Vaatame, Kas Ta töötab ja lähme teeme pausi.
Õpetaja: Teeme refresh.
Õpetaja: Ma võin korra panna ka Vaata siia meetodisse. Vähemalt ühe asja. Ma panen korra väikse Alerdi ka siia. Esialgu et alert,
Õpetaja: et me näeme, et see Transaction Type idimist tuleb sisse.
Õpetaja: On see sama, mida me hetkel ka siin kõrval näeme.
Õpetaja: Nii, mina vajutan.
Õpetaja: Noh, Stoplightse lootus veits. Ma vajutan siia tuli alt. Väärtus kaks tehakse täiesti uus massiiv
Õpetaja: ja ühel nendest. Nüüd See väärtus pannakse tagurpidi võrreldes sellega, mis sekund tagasi Oli Ütleme nii nii,
Õpetaja: Alerdi. Võtame maha. Lähen tagasi sinna Checkboxide juurde, Kustutan ära selle
Õpetaja: Aa, selle numbri. Vaata, meil ei ole vaja neid näha, aga see on jälle teil hästi hea teada, et taustal on objektid, mis niiöelda seda asja Aa, mille põhjal nagu visuaal kokku pannakse. Ja need andmed on kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: See on supertähtis, kui meil on näiteks niimoodi, et, Ee, me tahame teha mingisuguseid, et sa valid näiteks Mustamäe prisma ja tahad minna sinna vaatesse? Kus sa
Õpetaja: siis sul on Tegelikult, vaja teada et sa oled täiesti uuele vaatele. Sa pead tooma konkreetselt selle asukoha andmed ära peegeldama. Neid siin vormil ja nii edasi, vaata onju siis See koht, kus sa klikid.
Õpetaja: Ainult see koht tegelikult taustal teab. Vaata, mis on selle location id.
Õpetaja: Sa ei peaks tal ei ole mitte midagi teha. See on nagu andmebaas. See primer I kivi väärtus, onju? Midagi teha. Sellega Aga taustal jutt käib alati. Nagu Noh, meie andmed on seotud nende idega. Sa tahad mingisugust asja muuta. Sul on vaja tema Id D teada, et sa leiaksid andmebaasis õige rea ülesse
Õpetaja: ära muuta.
Õpetaja: Aa, töötab. Noh, üks viimane Refresh ka veel. Vaatame korra.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen selle lahti. Selle voebloki. Ja siis teeme ja ütleme ära, Ee, sellele asjale päris lõpuni pole tehtud. Aga pausile lähme. Ikka.
Õpetaja: Meid huvitab lihtsalt see Location objekt. Kui ma valin linna muutus, kui ma ütlen. Aa,
Õpetaja: kui ma ütlen. Automaatide arv. Sada Ahah Panite midagi tähele Mina panen midagi tähele.
Õpetaja: Ennem oli see meeles.
Õpetaja: No ma teen vaatamas. Vaadake, see location on ilusti meil number. Vaatame, mis värvi on.
Õpetaja: Sinine.
Õpetaja: Mis ülesse? Flow String. Sellepärast, et jah, see kastis. Me oleme öelnud, et Type on number, aga tema jaoks on see ikkagi string. Ee, selle teeme kohe korda. See on seal Location Formi all. No kui Te tulete kohe järgi, siis ma lihtsalt teen ise korda. Aa, see siin. Näete. Aa, meil
Õpetaja: emiititakse Event I.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on input input Ja ta Taip Taip on isegi ei vale asi.
Õpetaja: Number of Htms.
Õpetaja: Ee, tema type on number Aga see target value on ikkagi tema jaoks. Kui String me peame seda Castima,
Õpetaja: on see, et sa muudad ühe objekti teiseks Noh, hästi, spetsiifilisel viisil siin konstruktoriga, ma pigem ütlen, et. Kuule, ole hea.
Õpetaja: Teise numbriks Refresh.
Õpetaja: Noh, äkki nüüd siis saab? Vali linn. Tallinn, Vali asukoht. Aa Automaatide arv. Sada.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis siin all. Pool on, ee, täiesti ära saand.
Õpetaja: Ma panen raha sisse ja maksed, et oleks hästi spetsiifiline Transaction types False.
Õpetaja: Mm, False, Kõik on Falls Id mulle, Tundub, et ei tööta. Jah,
Õpetaja: ma ei viitsi ta all oleks olnud
Õpetaja: viimane,
Õpetaja: aga ei muutu ja võibolla peab korra ma klikkima mujale. See asi ei ole nagu. Väga.
Õpetaja: No on õige. True Falls True
Õpetaja: Siin oli see, et ta ei renderdanud valid pildi.
Õpetaja: No Ma valin mingi pildi. Nüüd me tahame ju image data all ka midagi näha. Mingi screenshot siin.
Õpetaja: See on see, et kuvatakse ja näidatakse, Aga nüüd on küsimus, et. Oota, Aga mis meil?
Õpetaja: Mis meil on? Siin, onju? Ma korra klikin, eksju? Mujale Jälle location. Kas image data on mingi base. Kuuskümmend neli. Mingi monster
Õpetaja: string,
Õpetaja: Nagu ei usu, Ma võtan kogu selle sisu. Me ei hakka seda näitama. See See on Streng. Ühesõnaga, me oleme nüüd seal maal. Kus ee, siis? Tehniliselt võttes Meil on need andmed nüüd kahtepidi. Kõik, mis on meil Location. Objekti küljes Flow ad alla
Õpetaja: Ja kõik, mida me muudame tuleb üles, tagasi,
Õpetaja: Lähme teeme siis ee pausi ja siis, ee, paneme lõpuni välja, Teeme siis viisteist pensioni, nagu alati.
Õpetaja: Ma teen komite ära.
Õpetaja: Jumala Ee, Viimane muutus oli see, et me panime jah selle numbri sisse
Õpetaja: see jah, et sisuliselt oli ennem oli.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, aga all tegelt meie.
Õpetaja: Ma korra teen korra üldse uue haru. Vaata, et oleks,
Õpetaja: Ma saan nagu aru praegu, et New Branch
Õpetaja: panen siia veel praegult hetkel video. Üks
Õpetaja: kreet Aa, Okei, ma üldist annan Kakskümmend neli
Õpetaja: video, üks Great Noh, seal mõned kommit. Id on juba sees, mis me oleme jõudnud teha, veel onju? Aga suures pildis.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen tagasi selle haaru peale, mida Mille kallal me praegu mässame?
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: nojah, ma saan nagu mitte tagasi, et mul ei ole aega seda niimoodi pärast käsitsi vaadata, Nüüd ma Teen nüüd kohe endal selle Comiti ära Ja siis saate ka
Õpetaja: Committee.
Õpetaja: Nii ma jätan selle. Push I. Ma panen pausile. Proovime siis meeles hoida.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: see on ka tõesti. Mida? Ma olen mitu korda juba rääkinud ja öelnud, et et ma tõesti tegelikult soovitan, et kui te Lähete koju alguses? Harjutage tõesti veel veel kord. Nagu kõike Seda nii nagu tegime. Lihtsalt et kinnistada.
Õpetaja: Ja kui teil tõesti seal on, nüüd Jätkuvalt on aega ja tahate kuidagi ennast edasi arendada. Siis pigem keskenduge, et lähme nüüd. Voe nagu edasiarendustele. Selles mõttes, et ee veel võimalused Kuidas asja natuke teistmoodi teha, onju? Uurida, kas kaalutluseks seda type onju, et. Okei, kuidas see käib ja mis ma teistmoodi pean tegema,
Õpetaja: no Ja siis sealt juba järgmine samm võiks olla Composition api. Aga ma ütlengi. Teil peaksid olema need fundamentaalsed asjad üsna selged juba kui enne Kui ta sinna api suunas liigute. Sellepärast, et seal on nagu. Tõesti. See kirjaviis on teistsugune. Seal ei ole niukest struktuuri, nagu meil siin on?
Õpetaja: Ee, seal on päris palju fookuspookust mis tehakse taustal ära karukõhus.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja tegelikult, kui hakata küsima, et kuule, mis asi see on ju Too siis. Ta hakkab nagu rääkima nendest samadest asjadest, et. Vaata, see on nagu kombineeritud, et ei mitt nagu. Alla. Aa, et siin, Nagu Siis see kohe läheb. Ee, vabandust, et Propsiga tuleb alla. Mitt läheb ülesse pikalt lahti. Kirjutan oleks siuke. Sa vaatad. Aa, okei, see On See sama asi,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, mida rohkem on nagu ee, seda abstraktsiooni ja karukõus, toimuvaid asju, siis seda
Õpetaja: ja ja siis seda raske Seda Seda raskem oleks teil tegelikult kuskil tööst pärast hakkama saadavad. Kui teil ei ole nagu neid fundamentaalseid teadmisi
Õpetaja: kui hakkakski kuskil tegema kohe Nagu Composition Api D ja pole kunagi kokku puutunud, et, ee, siis ei saaks aru.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ütlen, et seal seal taustal toimetavad need Samad asjad
Õpetaja: taustal. Toimetajad. Täpselt need samad võtted, mida me siin kasutame. Nii leidsime selle ühe veakoha ka üles, Onju Võibolla kuskil on, veel
Õpetaja: Kus saaks tegelikult lihtsalt üle. Vaadata On see, et kui sa otsid igalt poolt nagu üle projekti ee ja mitte onju, siis
Õpetaja: ee. Tulevad Kõik failid igal pool saaks, vaadata, et. Kas siin all on? Ei, mits Vaata,
Õpetaja: et Näed. Ei, Mitt on on ju siin komponendis, aga puudub.
Õpetaja: See oleks pigem Niukene Cloud I teema käi läbi,
Õpetaja: et, noh, praegu on puudu Ja vaata, ma alguses ei pannud neid,
Õpetaja: Okei, seda Võibki võibolla teha. Ee, aga praegult, mis me tahame teha, on siis seda, et meil parentis on nüüd info olemas
Õpetaja: Ja vaadake, kui mõinna on nüüd kui me.
Õpetaja: Mm, mis siin viga on?
Õpetaja: Component has been registers but not use.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Ma olen kogemata. On Aa tekkinud transaction Type Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga tegelikult seal Location formi sees on.
Õpetaja: Ta ütleb seda et siin Html is mitte Ühte ainsat korda Sa ei kasuta. Seda Transaction type checkbox. I et miks sul see siin on?
Õpetaja: See on väga hea küsimus, Mul ei ole ühtegi head põhjust. I love Optimizing läheb see ka, minema,
Õpetaja: et algselt, kui ma tegin, siis ta korraks oli.
Õpetaja: Aga jäi, Kes selle ee, Teata andis, seda, ei andnud Tegelikult intellige ei oma tarkusega, vaid eeslint,
Õpetaja: mis taustal toimetab.
Õpetaja: Ribaalselt kuidas mulle kaos oli.
Õpetaja: Sa Võid et siit siit kustutasid ära selle aa,
Õpetaja: Et senikaua, kuni see on kasutusel, siis ta ei saa ära minna.
Õpetaja: Ja siin oli ennem
Õpetaja: nüüd põhiline asi, mis meile nüüd näiteks, vaatame, Kuidas Ka siin on nüüd asjad tegelikult päris hästi.
Õpetaja: Aga meil on veel ikkagi üks. Ee, komponent on veel tegemata.
Õpetaja: See on tuttav asi, Pilt taaskis. On öeldud, et see peaks olema üks komponent. Atm image.
Õpetaja: No aga teeme selle ära, siis on kõik, siis on nagu tõesti Kõik nagu, mis puutub komponentidesse.
Õpetaja: Citystraptown üks. Ja siis on.
Õpetaja: Aga Pange tähele, et siin on see vee ese, onju? Kõik, mis on siin Sees selle kool I sees.
Õpetaja: Tehke siniseks. Vaadake hästi ettevaatlikult.
Õpetaja: Parem klõps,
Õpetaja: Factor ja Ekstract View komponent.
Õpetaja: Eighty Atm.
Õpetaja: Hästi, kiired piirangas. Mul oli Seal mitmuses. Ma pigem pakun, et mitte ainsus. Ikka. Jah, nii Atm imag.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on jälle see olukord, et, Ee, vot siit see on nüüd ainult komponent, on ju? Ta kuvab. Siin ei ole mingit interaktiivsust.
Õpetaja: Ee, Okei, template või? Noh, script. I tõstame alla. Nii on lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Ütleme vaikselt Kahetsen. Äkki oleks võinud teha selle grupiga Selle muudatuse et oleks, koguaeg üleval
Õpetaja: Ee. Nüüd siin on ka, et mida me tegelikult kasutame. On image. Data on nii,
Õpetaja: Aga meie saime kaasa. Propsina
Õpetaja: kogu Location I et vahetame kahes kohas ära, et siin, kus me Anname kaasa. Kavatseme anda kaasa Ainult osaliselt, et ainult seda image Data T läheb vaja.
Õpetaja: Võibolla niimoodi, et kustutad selle Location i siit ära, Onju alla Highlight Ib ka, et kahes kohas on kasutatud. Kui on tühi, siis näita seda. Kui on sisu, Näita seda sisu, et kui Me kustutame selle siit ära.
Õpetaja: Inimeste data on alla joonitud. Kustutame siit ka ära.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et ei, aga image data tulebki siia sisse, Mis Tema tüüp on string.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on. Me tegime niiöelda ise käsitsi. Muudatuse Childis
Õpetaja: tuleb teha see sama liigutus ära. On ju, et ütleme, et Ei, ei, siin. On Propsina image data ja küljest image Data.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis läheme siia variantisse. Ütleme, et ei, ei
Õpetaja: control töiks, siin on Image. Data
Õpetaja: saab ka nii et hakata kirjutama siin seda image ja tuleb juba, onju?
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et Location I sees See läheb ainult Osaliselt,
Õpetaja: No võibolla I Love optimizing sihat. Kui kuskil midagi on, siis tõstab veits ilusamaks.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd selles mõttes, et nüüd kujutage ette, kui Palju koodi Tegelikult nendes Just Html I osas.
Õpetaja: Meil oli tegelikult ta ennem mingi hetk. Me vaatasimegi kaheksakümmend üheksa rida või midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, Kui kokku on kuivanud meie Html praegu poole võrra
Õpetaja: Ja see on kood, mis ei ole endal nagu silme ees.
Õpetaja: No ja kui veel natuke ennast aidata ka. Vaata, mis mind Huvitab. Onju, et meil on see dropdown form ja image
Õpetaja: ja all on järgmises Lause nimi džinput Ja viimastes on siis need tagasi Ja lisa nupud.
Õpetaja: Kuidas siis vaadata? Visuaali ei ole vale asi.
Õpetaja: Roheline eksitab.
Õpetaja: See kaheks ei näita niimoodi. Aa, näe. Kui panna target ikkagi midagi näitab. Vaata, näitab, et see
Õpetaja: on Transaction Tai Checkbox.
Õpetaja: Ta näitab asukohta, on ju? Ainult, aga midagi näitab
Õpetaja: nüüd seda. Jälle Näitab vaata. Näed? Number of
Õpetaja: Location Name input. Need on kõik niiöelda neid. No see see on nagu tema arvates Location Users. Ta ei saa aru, et see on kuidagi
Õpetaja: tegelikult Cities.
Õpetaja: Okei, no see annab täpsema ülevaate Tegelikult kui me hakkame niimoodi lahti tegema.
Õpetaja: Location Viewl on, et Ee City Strop Town Vorm kas. Seda saab kuidagi liigutada aga?
Õpetaja: Mm Select Component In page Noh. See, teebki Seda juba vist.
Õpetaja: Okei, jah, seda See vajab veits veel uurimist. Kuidas seda saab? Võibolla veel efektiivsemalt kasutada Nii, ee, info nüüd olemas. Hakkame nüüd rääkima sellest nupust lõpus ka.
Õpetaja: No tagasi. Nupp on. Aa, Selle saaks isegi inlinen iga teha.
Õpetaja: Aga teeme seda pärast. Pigem huvitab meid Ikkagi see asi, Lisa.
Õpetaja: Kuna see on nüüd kõige peamisem meetod üldse, mis siin on, siis mina paneksin selle meetodite võttes. Pärast tõstame meetodid ka võibolla paika, kui aega jääb.
Õpetaja: Ee, et hakkame nüüd siis seda kontrolli tegema.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ütlen ära, et see ei pea tingimata olema Nii, mis puudutab nagu neid vorme, siis meil on võimalik tegelikult seda teha. Ka
Õpetaja: Atml I on need elemendid sisse ehitatud. Sa saad ta panna nagu vormitäägide vahele. Ja sa saad nagu veits ära automatiseerida Seda, et Browser ise ütleb, et sul, on see täitmata ja tühi ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga mina tahaks teha niukest lahendust, et. Ee. Me ikkagi ütleme kasutajale nagu, Aa ise. Programmiliselt Eriti kuna meil on mingid niisugused asjad Tal on keeruline niikuinii seda automaatselt ära, teha.
Õpetaja: Et me teeme sellise lahenduse,
Õpetaja: et esiteks meil on vaja alerti. Kus Alert võiks tulla, Kui midagi on halvasti. Aa, ta vist oli Heideri all siin pildil. Kuskil
Õpetaja: seal siin all oli need errorid on ju
Õpetaja: üleval. Ikka eelmisel Vist oli ka üleval, On ju kuskil. Me tegime ka ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, varasemalt, kus me tegime seda sisse. Logimisel Tegime vist vä Okei,
Õpetaja: nii, No see on. See on ju.
Õpetaja: Täida Kõik väljad on üleval. Võtame siis selle sama. Niiöelda süsteemi.
Õpetaja: Ee, no siin ei olegi midagi vaja teha, et esialgu on vaja, et ee, üldse seda visuaalset saaks olla. Meil,
Õpetaja: kus ta võiks minna? Mis Me just ütlesime, et ta võiks minna. Heederi ülesse, on nii?
Õpetaja: Siin võib juba ettenägelikult natuke piirata. Ka mingi kolm. Mina ei tea neli. Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, et tuleme siia. Mis on need tähed, mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Mida me tahame siin kasutada taaskasutada?
Õpetaja: Jah, A ja E, onju,
Õpetaja: Ee, alert A ja E ka Üks peab siin Hästi, natukene tüütu. Näiteks et. Jaavas. Ta alati valib esimese valiku, et kui Tab I panna, siin, peab nool alla korra minema
Õpetaja: ja tahab aitama. Ja Ütleme, ee, see kaldkriips. Nii öelda, et see on üksik tag.
Õpetaja: Tema ootab all Si Aa, see ootab propsina Error message it. Esialgu võib panna mingi. Aa
Õpetaja: näeme, et ta tõesti on. Ta on kuskil vasakul pool Noh, see on see ro värk, Vaata Justify
Õpetaja: Content Center.
Õpetaja: Ennem see ei paistnud välja. Miks, Sest et tekst on? Vaata, ta võtab, et tekst on alati keskel kõikidel nendel asjadel siin, onju? Ja. Ja ennem, kuna see heeder oli. Lihtsalt vaata kogu laiuses. Siis ta oligi täpselt keskel niipea, kui me ütlesime, et Ei, tema laius on pisikene. Siis ta korraks kolis. Siia, vasakule poole, On ju
Õpetaja: nii? Tema? Loomulikult me paneme elama samamoodi muutuja pealt Error message, et see on dünaamiline. Me oleme sellest juba rääkinud, onju?
Õpetaja: Korra võib praegu siin alla hüpata, õigesse kohta, et vajutada näiteks kuskil mingi Muutuja peale Control ja klikk.
Õpetaja: Satume kohe data. Bloki, onju? Mõte oli siia kiirelt saa saada. Siia võiks teha uue muutuja Error Message.
Õpetaja: Miks Seda meil on vaja. Vaata, et me saame vajadusel visata mingit viga. Siis Error message kaudu. Me hakkame seda tegema
Õpetaja: No jah, nüüd hoida Nool vasakule, et peaks ülesse tagasi vist sattuma, on ju Näete, siin kus me oleme?
Õpetaja: Mis me siin nüüd teeme? Kuidas ma saan öelda, Siit error message.
Õpetaja: Noh, tuleb veel ikka raskelt. See on tag I sees.
Õpetaja: Kool on.
Õpetaja: Ei, me ei taha location it location i sees Ei ole, ei ole.
Õpetaja: No sa mõtlesid siin.
Õpetaja: No, igal juhul me tahame nüüd kasutada seda error messagit, aga et ta saaks aru, et See ei ole mingi string. Aa, enam on ju
Õpetaja: vaid on error. Message
Õpetaja: vaikimisi. Midagi ei näidata, sest et terror message, kui me tuleme, Siis tal on alguses vaikeväärtusena tühjas.
Õpetaja: Kui siin panna jälle see. Aa, siis ta loomulikult ilmub. Siia On ju
Õpetaja: nii? See võib isegi korraks siin ees olla. Aga meil ei ole seda rohkem vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd me peame minema siis sinna kohta, kus Seda, nuppu vajutatakse. Ja vaatame, et mis meil siin praegu on? Disainitud mitte midagi. Meil on vaja mingit meetodit,
Õpetaja: mida selle nupuga käivitad, on nii ät Click ja midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kuna see on klikitav asi, siis meetodite mõttes. Mina teeksin selle meetodi siia.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks olla selle meetodi nimi? Hoiame seda hästi Niukseks nagu äriloogilisena. Mitte nagu niisuguse tehnilisena,
Õpetaja: mida me tahame teha. Mida me tahame teha kui ma vajutan Lisa.
Õpetaja: Jah, seeder ütleb ära ja
Õpetaja: Adussõda, Niukene, roosa või musta auto. Aga mina paneks lihtsalt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Mida sa siin ikka ad Id Vanat location It ei saa panna, on ju Ad Old Location,
Õpetaja: Siis see New on natukene niukene ebavajalik. Otseselt ei ole teda vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on muidugi See sama. Add New Location.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina pakun, et me peaksime siin sama lähenemise võtma. Nüüd, vaata, et ega me ei saa kohe Location It hakata lisama kõige Esimene asi, kui võib tulla mingisugune
Õpetaja: error message, siis kõige esimene asi võiks teha, seda et nupu aitad.
Õpetaja: Kuidagi ette ei jääks mingi valemiga meil sinna Forever and Ever Selliseks olukorraks, kus teda enam ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ma ütleks seda, et error message iga kord kui nuppu vajutame, Siis tema algväärtus on tühistreening.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd edasi. Ad Location on hetkel Hall Võiks kohe selle ka ära lahendada. Mis meil mõte oli? Noh, Kes,
Õpetaja: kes seda peaks käivitama?
Õpetaja: Klik, klikk, klikk. Onju, tuleme. Otsime selle õige nupu. Lisa nupp,
Õpetaja: tuleme siia, Paneme kohe ette. Ät, klikk, klikk, Klikk
Õpetaja: Click võrdub ja siit. Mis ta nimi oli? Ad
Õpetaja: Location Paar tähta panna ja panna A ja L. Näiteks
Õpetaja: nii nüüd kui siin vajutada. Kontroll B. Vaata siis sinna ma kukungi. Ja nüüd, nagu me saame nende kahe vahel niimoodi taielda.
Õpetaja: See töötab nüüd niimoodi, et ee, Vaadake
Õpetaja: niipidi ma kindlalt tean, et kuhu reale ta satub. Ta satub sinna reale. Kus see meetod on defineeritud, on nii, Controll, B või Klikk, mis iganes, Kontroll B
Õpetaja: Sest et kahte kohta ei saa samanimelist meetodit ka niiöelda, teha, et ma ei saa olla nagu see asi, Oleks nagu. Vau, kuhu sa lähed üldse? Ta läheb üldse kuhugi. Metsa läheb Nüüd juba. On ju,
Õpetaja: et niimoodi ei saa olla
Õpetaja: kahte samanimelist Meetodit ei saa olla. Seega kui ma kuskil seda esile kutsun, Mingit meetodid ma juba vaimusilmas Tean ette, et ta läheb sinna, kohta, kus See meetod on defineeritud.
Õpetaja: Aga vaadake vastupidi, Praegult on ainult ühes kohas. Kus on see meetod välja kutsutud? Kui Ma ütlen kontroll, B, või Klikk. Mis iganes, siis ta läheb sinna kohta, kus on seda välja kutsutud. Aga kui ma teen kopi ja panen siia, mina ei tea kohe Templeti algusse. Reale kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu vajutan, kuhu ma kukun?
Õpetaja: Katsun alla, aga ma praegult vajutan. Kuhu ma kukun mitte kuhugi veel
Õpetaja: sellepärast et nüüd on kahes kohas seda kasutatud. Nüüd ta ütleb, et näed siin failis Real Kaks ja nelikümmend. Üks on seda kasutatud. Ta Annab nüüd mulle võimaluse, et kui sa lähed asja peale, mis on kuskil defineeritud, siis Ta ju läheb alati ühte kohta, Aga kasutuse mõttes, et kus on seda kasutatud, võib olla mitmeid. Kui ma ütlen, selle, siis ma kukun siia,
Õpetaja: Ma tulen, vajutan uuesti ja vajutan selle alumise, Siis ma kukun siia.
Õpetaja: Noh, et seda saab ka nagu navigeerimiseks. Kasutada Üsna edukalt. Noh, ma võtan selle Control X ära, Siit on ju
Õpetaja: on vasakule ja olen jälle, tagasi, onju? Nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, mis veel,
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd. Minu vaimu silmas on niimoodi et ennem ei ole mõtet sõnumit saata, Kui kõik on, hästi.
Õpetaja: Et mina pakun, et siia, peaks tegema niukse Ifelso olukorra, onju
Õpetaja: Ja mina pakun, et me teeme sellise lahenduse, Kuna siin on mitu erinevat errormessed, mis võib olla. Ma Korra kommenteerin, välja, et ma saaks koodi näidata. Siin on mitu erinevat olukorda, mis Võib olla valesti
Õpetaja: sa ei ole linn
Õpetaja: valinud. Sa ei ole asukohta täitnud. Sa ei ole automaatide arvu vähemalt ühte valinud. Sa pole ühtegi Nendest valinud pilt oli vabatahtlik. Siin taskis. Seda ei pea kontrollima,
Õpetaja: sest minu mõte on see, et meil on erinevaid olukordi. Me ei hakka Tegema mingeid miljon T, vaid. Me teeme ühe väga lihtsa võtte, et meie plaan on see.
Õpetaja: Valideerime veaolukorrad
Õpetaja: nii ja ma panen two Siis, on niimoodi paremini. Paistab, et ongi tegevus ka.
Õpetaja: Kui on mingi viga
Õpetaja: viga, siis täida ära.
Õpetaja: Error. Message on see arusaadav. See on meie Plaan
Õpetaja: ja nüüd If iga. Me tahame teha ülikavalalt seda asja. Vaata, et kui error message
Õpetaja: on tühi, siis meie jaoks ei ole ühtegi Errorit saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Me kavatseme teha nii nii hästi, sest et siis annab see meil manageerida seda, et me saame Error message visata Ja visatakse vähemalt mingisugune viga on Mõte Selge
Õpetaja: on erinevad. Muidu me tahame vaadata, kui me hakkasime panema, et kui linn on täis, ma Ei tea, viska viga, kui on. Aa, üks checkbox. Valimata. Viska viga. Mingi nagu ei taha.
Õpetaja: See on väga lihtne. See kusjuures jääb. See sama asi. Vaata, Re settimine jääb veel kenasti sinna valideerimise sisse.
Õpetaja: See on nagu plaan,
Õpetaja: sest et iga kord, kui hakkad valideerima, siis algseis on see, et ei ole ühtegi viga.
Õpetaja: Ja siis vaatad üle need kõik need asjad? Kas äkki on viga saate mõttest aru?
Õpetaja: Meil on Plaan, et kui me. Kui meil on kõik hästi,
Õpetaja: siis siin on see To. Do.
Õpetaja: Saada sõnum Packi.
Õpetaja: Kui ei saa seda näidata,
Õpetaja: siis Valideerimine täidab error message niikuinii ära ja kasutajale Näidatakse mingit viga, aga sõnumit ei saada ennem ära. Kui kõik on hästi,
Õpetaja: on see arusaadav me Ei, saada sõnumit enne. Meil ei ole pointi saata. Ja Seal on veel loomulikult see võimalus, et tuleb ka vastuse, et kuule ei sobi. Seda Peame ka Handlima.
Õpetaja: Nüüd valideerime. Veaolukorra. Ei ole mõtet seda koodi siia kirjutada ja. Ja hakata Seda
Õpetaja: teeme kohe. No me võime teha. Vaata selle niimoodi sellisel kujul ära, et ütleme siia viis punkt väliteid form,
Õpetaja: korrekt, infot, Midagi taolist
Õpetaja: niukest meetodit. Tahan välja kutsuda meetod, Mis asub Siin See on abi meetod. Getwater, Mäletate, on ju? See on siin peameetod.
Õpetaja: Meie cappuccino See on kutsud välja Get my Water
Õpetaja: No kui me tulemegi selle kollase joone juurde, ütleme et tee, see viga. Great Function
Õpetaja: hoopis kuskile. Siia alla. Selle Tulge võtke see lihtsalt Ära Need kolm rida. Vaata, et. Ee. Lähme ikka,
Õpetaja: et ta jääks selle meetodi esimeseks abimeetodiks. See on see plaan väike koma ka siia Validate Forum Correct input.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi. Ta tegi selle praegu kõige alla, Et mäletad, kui me tegime niimoodi, et me ekstraktisime meetodist ta toppis Ülesse
Õpetaja: kohe. Meetod üles. Niimoodi kaela Tegime mingi koodi siniseks. Ütlesin, et tee sest meetod A. Nüüd on see, et me viitame, et me Kutsume välja mingid meetodid. Seda pole olemas. Ta tegi meile selle põhja ise ära.
Õpetaja: No kuidas selle valmis teed? Tegelt Vahet pole, oleks võinud ka niimoodi tulla siia. Ega see meega eriliselt praegult ma aega ei säästnud. Noh,
Õpetaja: sama sama, onju
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd siin. Siis on plaanis see, et selle asja me võime siit ära võtta. Et iga kord,
Õpetaja: enne kui me hakkame seda Error message it täitma, siis lähte lähtestame ta ära, et ei ole midagi siin
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siis peame hakkama vaatama.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas on Elu nüüd väga mõnus, mida me peame vaatama,
Õpetaja: Okei, Te mõtlete, et me peame ma ma teen ettepaneku. Vaata, mida me peame vaatama, et vali tee kasutaja, on valinud vähemalt ühe linna.
Õpetaja: Jah, Mida Mille ideed?
Õpetaja: City Okei, Davai, Mis Ma kirjutan
Õpetaja: No praegult esimese sõna ikka. Teate, millega alustame?
Õpetaja: Mingi If peab olema. On ju? Tehke see mingi keha ka juba ära.
Õpetaja: Mida sa tahtsid vaadata? Mingid ideed Nüüd ütle sina mulle, mis ideed me vaatame selles mõttes aga nüüd mõtleme.
Õpetaja: Me peamegi ideed vaatama. Ja sa isegi ütlesid ära, ka mis sa teed, aga paneme lihtsalt selle, kirja.
Õpetaja: No kui ma kirjutan. City Id ei võrdu nulliga.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on temal nagu probleem. Nagu et millest sa räägid? Nagu sulle mõte on õige
Õpetaja: Sul mõte on õige, Aga objekt on vale.
Õpetaja: Aga korra ma küsin. Nagu. Aga kus kohas on meil need? Id D.
Õpetaja: Ah, aa, Ahaa Location i all. No Mis ma siis kirjutan?
Õpetaja: No location Punkt ei anna ka midagi veel.
Õpetaja: This mixed this. Me oleme skrip I sees. Me oleme siin all Location.
Õpetaja: Kas nii sobiks?
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, No Tervet. Objekti ei võrdle nulliga, vaid siit seest, mis me tahame vaadata.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, me saame öelda et Ei, võrdu null aga oleks igasuguseid muid variante. Ka. Ehitus on nagu niuke. Natuke nagu on, onju? Ee, teine variant oleks ka see, et on, ee.
Õpetaja: Jaa, mulle meeldiks see natukene rohkem. Vaata, et seal on nagu see eeldab, et siis seal City Id S on mingi väärtus. Mida saab üldse võrrelda, et päriselt seal sisu on,
Õpetaja: et Ee City Id on suurem Kui null, siis me teame, et null on ju kõik linnad või? Vali see linn, on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Aga meil on vaja nüüd siin teha natukene teistmoodi. Ee, sellepärast, et meil ei Ole vaja hoopis tegelikult. Happy Bath I.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja öelda seda. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: meil on vaja öelda. Näiteks siin, et vali
Õpetaja: vali vähemalt Üks linn.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on vaja. Meil on vaja. See. Meil on see ifi Sisu. Peab olema nagu selles mõttes negatiivne olukord, et meil on mingi probleem. Ja me tahame eratäita,
Õpetaja: et praegult on niimoodi, et kui on mingi linn valitud siis error, message on vali vähemalt vähemalt Üks linn, Vaata, onju Või vali mingi linn,
Õpetaja: siis on võrdub, onju? Mis on veelgi parem tegelikult, et on hästi konkreetne olukord, et kui City Id on null, Siis me teame, et vähemalt ühe linna peaks valima. Vali vähemalt. Ee, Vali mingi linn. Näiteks Vali, vali linn, vali Mingi linn. No see sõnastus ei oma tähtsust,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd oleks selles mõttes niimoodi, et tal on nagu mure, tal on Nagu Mure selle konkreetse asjaga.
Õpetaja: Nii, No aga vaatame, kas ee. See töötaks praegult sellisel kujul, et hakkame Step by Step minema, et.
Õpetaja: No Aga see ongi see probleem. Noh, kas ma olen linna valinud? See ongi see. Vaata, et kui ma vajutan, nüüd mine siis. Tal on nagu. Et Kuule,
Õpetaja: vali mingi linn. Kui ma valin nüüd selle Tallinna, siis ta vist jätab mind rahule, on ju?
Õpetaja: Nii, No päris Ife. Asjadest ma nüüd ei pääse. Vaata, et selles mõttes me vaatame meedia menüükse lahenduse, et ta näitab ainult ühe vea, mis on praegult, millega Tal on enamus kohad. Aa, enamus vormid, mida mina olen pigem uis näinud.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on midagi täitmata ja seal on mingi konkreetne sisu, Mida ta ootab. Vaata, see on. See on väga suur vahe. Vaata, kas kass on täitsa tühi või seal on midagi valesti.
Õpetaja: Aa, enamus Asjad tavaliselt näitavad ühte asja Korraga. Olete teinud seda. Te aidate mingit vormi, ja siis te olete, et. Jah, Next, vaata või midagi taolist, siis ütleb. Ei, ei, sellega on mingi jama. Vaata, see on Aa, okei, okei, okei, okei, Lähed teed selle korda? Vaata, vajutad. Next ütleb. Kuule, nüüd on mingi järgmine asi, mis seal on pigem näeb rohkem niukest.
Õpetaja: Kõik on võimalik. Nagu Programmeeriks. Saab ka teha niimoodi, et ta Nagu teeb kõik punaseks ja. Ja nii edasi oma töödest tehtud staate. Vaata, on ju, et. Ee. Mina olen siin valmis. Sellega suunalt Öeldakse Et ühte asja korraga,
Õpetaja: et kasutaja on fokusseeritud. Siis nagu
Õpetaja: kuhu ta. Kuhu ta läheb? Me saaks teha massiivi ka ja korjata kokku kõik Sõnumid palju, Vähemalt üks linn. Me võime kõike teha. Me võime, mida iganes teha.
Õpetaja: Võime ka. Võime ka teistmoodi. Teha.
Õpetaja: Ma olen nõus siis seda tegema. Kui Harrael on, võin küsida korra, kas on või ei ole, Siis ma oleks nõus tegema.
Õpetaja: Aa, korra.
Õpetaja: Kas Ee Jaovail on ka Push, Meetod midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Oi, kui halvasti see tuli Davai, siis võime nii ka teha.
Õpetaja: Võime nii ka teha. Teeme siis lihtsalt Siis Siis on niimoodi, et ei ole Ifi elsesi, vaid on If Id lihtsalt siin.
Õpetaja: Me teeme niukse. Ee, asja nagu
Õpetaja: Ee, Kuidas ta lõpus välja näeb. Me peame hästi natuke vaatama. Seda ka, aga ütleme. Saame selle kuidagi kokku. Teeme korra Ühe Muutuja Led
Õpetaja: Error Metsa käes võrdub.
Õpetaja: Näete, see peaks juba tegema. Arrae. Ta ütleb, et seda ei ole veel kasutatud, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis me peame tegema niimoodi. Noh, iga kord, kui me vajutame, siis see ongi tühi.
Õpetaja: Oi, kuule, vale koht. Ju ma tahtsin minna siia.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et error message on alati tühi Ja meil on error messages. Mis on tühi massiiv. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Nüüd meie tahame siin öelda. Vaata, et kui sinul on biif, siin selle See sõnum võib alles jääda korraks, et ta saab Copida. Kui siin. On meil mingi Biif,
Õpetaja: vali mingi linn, siis me ütleme praegu. Siin See error. Tal on nüüd meetod. Massiivil on meetod nimega Push.
Õpetaja: Ja Meie ütleme, et lükka siia niisugune
Õpetaja: niukene String nagu vali mingi linn
Õpetaja: Paneks võibolla Semi koloni otsa juba teades, mismoodi see asi hakkab välja paistma? Et kui tuleb mitu tükki kuidagi peab neid eraldama, Vaata on ju. No selle lõppsõnumiga tegelema on ju
Õpetaja: selle error Message. I Me Võtame siit ära. Vaata nüüd ühe asja Oleme ära vaadanud. Olete nõusad,
Õpetaja: Mis me lõpus kavatseme teha on see, et me ütleme This punkt. Error Messages.
Õpetaja: Ee, võrdub Error. Messages.
Õpetaja: Kas tal mingi tuust ringi laadne Ka asi on olemas. Huvitav, Boost ring.
Õpetaja: Ma pean vaatama, kuidas see välja näeb. Võibolla peab mingid korrektuurid seal tegema või mitte sellepärast, et See on massiiv, Ma ei saa. Vaata, see on väga erinev asi. Kui ma ütlen, et. Hei, This error messages võrdub. Error messages, Sa Lihtsalt see on jaama script. Me alustasime niimoodi, et on string.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ühel hetkel on hoopis seal massiiv.
Õpetaja: Näed, talle ei meeldi, isegi praegu et see ta ütleb. Kuule, joo, mis sa teed siin,
Õpetaja: et sa ise nagu ütled? Kainda, nagu et sa tahad ringi, aga nüüd Järsku ütled, et kuule et anna mulle hoopis üks. Ta annab objekti. Viite üle lihtsalt massiivi.
Õpetaja: Aga kui käivitad sellest samast massiivist meetodi, siis Ta lihtsalt teeb massiivi niiöelda stringi representatsiooniks. Võibolla paneme mingi kandilised sulud ja komad vahel. Noh, me näeme miuke see lõpus on on ju me juba praegu saame, vaadata, et milline see üks asi vähemalt on,
Õpetaja: et kui ma. Siis ma näen, mis ta ütleb selle kohta,
Õpetaja: vaid Ta on Lisa. Vali mingi linn ja tuleb niimoodi Me peame vaatama, kuidas see lõpus välja näeb.
Õpetaja: No ma võin kaks tükki panna ka korra lihtsalt järjest, et kui ma juba praegu mind kannatamatu olen, et kuidas nad nagu omavahel välja hakkavad nägema? Teen Refresh, I vajutan uuesti. Kujutage ette, et sinna listi on juba kaks asja lükatud.
Õpetaja: Ahah, mis ta teeb? Ta paneb koma ise vahele, kui on mitu asja
Õpetaja: Ta on päris tark. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, aga võibolla siis lihtsalt ei panegi neid
Õpetaja: Edaspidi onju? Jah, meil niikuinii saab olema üks. See on Järgmine asi, mis me tahame vaadata. Nüüd me ei pea El Seife iga tegema. Elsafe ga. Ma oleks pidanud tegema. Kui saab, siis jääd Ainult üks asi, siis ta võtab kõik esimese teise Condition It ta enam ei vaata.
Õpetaja: Kui me teeme nüüd hoopis. Järsku sellise lahenduse, et et Siin on midagi halvasti ja öeldakse kohe kõik korraga ära. Mis ei meeldi, siis me saame teha lihtsalt niimoodi järjest saame teha If E push Ida sinna listi järjest uusi. Niiöelda teateid.
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelikult isegi. Võibolla siis võib teha niimoodi. Et teeme tublikeid, vähendame oma jalavaeva, mis on järgmine asi. Mida peaks vaatama. Asukoht
Õpetaja: on ju.
Õpetaja: Ja meie luksus on see. Meil on juba ära progetud, et meil kõik andmed on siin Location is olemas see Ju peegeldabki. Meie vormi, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Me lihtsalt peame vaatama neid andmeid,
Õpetaja: et kas kõik on hästi? No Kui Location Name algab tühjast ringiga, siis kas see selleks seisust ta ei saa jääda on ju? Peab olema. No päriselus võib olla tahaks vaadata, et peab olema mingi paar tähemärki. Ka Keegi paneb linna A, B, nagu No on ju.
Õpetaja: Aga me meil niukseid tingimusi taskis ei Ole aga päriselus. Võibolla võiks nii. Olla.
Õpetaja: Siis on järgmine asi, et me ei vaata enam seda City Id, D, vaid vaatame
Õpetaja: seda Location Name I. Millal on meie jaoks siis viga?
Õpetaja: Meie jaoks on viga. Kui ta on endiselt ühistring.
Õpetaja: Kas kasutaja korra toksib siia midagi
Õpetaja: kohe seda korra toksiks ja midagi,
Õpetaja: kus otsustab ära kustutada. Kui ta vajutab lisa nuppu, siis meie jaoks on see Beef on ju
Õpetaja: neid sõnum on meil siin mitte vali mingi linn.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea. Täida asukoha nimi.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen jälle see sõnum. Mind Tegelikult üldse ei huvita, Nagu parem paned. Lisa peaks mõlemad olema. On ju? Vali mingi linn täidu asukohanimi.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: see, et ei ole siin tühikut ja asja. Vaata, Me manipuleerime seda stringi lõpus. Mingi replace. Iga natukene ilusamaks ja paremaks
Õpetaja: Praegult. Me seda ei muretse.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas bussilt saab mingit Parameetreid ka anda. Ma korra vaatan, kas tuleb midagi.
Õpetaja: Buss, buss.
Õpetaja: Pakun, et. Ee. Ei,
Õpetaja: ma ei saa tühikut ka panna sest koma tuleb teisele poole. No üks trikk on mis? On nii? Kui Chip saab olla?
Õpetaja: Ma panen neid niimoodi. Vaata tühiku siia,
Õpetaja: aga siis oleks nagu see. Vaata, et okei kasutaja ei näe seda. Vaata, onju. Praegult oleks enamvähem okei, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma teen nagu noh, ta, ei näe seda. See on nii väikene. Üks Space. Vaata, see oleks nii. See on. See on see kommentaar. See on häk, see pole ilus. Ma Täidan linna ära ja asukohta ei täida.
Õpetaja: Mis siin tegelikult ees on? Mis Siin on ees
Õpetaja: üks tühik, onju, et viisakam oleks teha seda teistmoodi. Me teemegi seda lõpustöötlust ka. Pead sellega õppima.
Õpetaja: Nii, Davai täidu asukoha nimi. No teeme nüüd. Ärge tublikaadi mis järgmine on? Siis
Õpetaja: järgmine on siis mis iganes sealt. Järgmine nimekirjas ta on.
Õpetaja: Aa Location Name on tehtud. Aa, number of onju? Onju? Järgmine
Õpetaja: number Kui number, of on endiselt. Ahah. Nüüd peab natukene mõtlema.
Õpetaja: No seda algseisu me ei taha panna. See ongi okei, on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Nüüd see koht on ka see. Vaata, et võiks panna null, onju, et kui on null, siis Oi, oi, oi, oi, aga mis siis, kui mi inimene paneb Sinna miinus üks on ju.
Õpetaja: Vot see on see koht, et meie jaoks on Beef siis, kui number of on
Õpetaja: Aga sa ei saa minust sisse minna ju.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, kas ta lubab ja miinust panna. Ei, luba nii üles.
Õpetaja: Ta ei luba. Vaata nendega alla minna. Aga Aga Kuidas on siis, kui ma kirjutan selle siia? Ma vaatan. Ma Ei, ole proovinud.
Õpetaja: Ta ei luba panna. Oot, oot, oot, No vaatame ka ära miinus lubab panna. Ja, noh, no läheks muidugi
Õpetaja: klikke. Ega see Htm, Vaata, see, et meil on pannud Html I sisse, et Meil see miinimum asi on üks. See ainult mõjutab tegelikult hetkel Ainult neid noolekesi.
Õpetaja: Meie äriloogikat ta kuidagi ei muuda, et me peame ikka, ise, aga meil on väga lihtne. Vaata, millal on meie jaoks probleem. Vaata, et Aa. No see sõnum saab olema. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Mm, vähemalt üks pangaautomaat peab olema. No see sõnum on nagu mingi Niukene. Väga lohisev Aga pangaautomaat
Õpetaja: peab olema või vanasti niimoodi, et, ee, Noh,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, see sõnum sõnumiks ülisavi,
Õpetaja: aga saate mõttest aru. Vaata, kuidagi. Viisakalt. Tahaks seda võibolla paremini, öelda aga me ei suuda mõelda, onju? Ja see on see, et see olukord on meie jaoks. Et kui on vähem kui
Õpetaja: te ütlesite, üks no ongi tegelt null, Ei tohi ka olla ju, Nii et klapib, et kui väärtus on väiksem kui üks, siis meie jaoks, on see Beef ja me push Ime jälle endale ühe
Õpetaja: sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Sinna juurde, on ju? Saab kohe proovida ka. Lisa,
Õpetaja: vali mingi lint. Täida asukoha. Nii nimi
Õpetaja: vist ei olnud. Refresh ei toiminud veel. Ma pakun, ma teen korra uuesti. Aa, Tähendab, mul oli nõuetekohane On ju? Sa panen korra null.
Õpetaja: Vali mingi lint, Täida asukoha. Nimi. Vähemalt üks pangaaod peab olema. Va? Noh, ma ei tea. Võibolla valitud näiteks siis kuidagi lõppeb ära.
Õpetaja: Või vali vähemalt üks Pangaautomaat. Noh, ma ei tea. Vali
Õpetaja: vähemalt üks pangaautomaat. Ma üritaks seda teksti hoida võimalikult lühikesena, kui hakkab neid sinna koonduma, ka nii töötab Onju,
Õpetaja: Mis järgmine?
Õpetaja: Jaa, vähemalt üks checkbox peab olema, et see on meie jaoks lubamatu olukord. Siin, praegu, See
Õpetaja: no siin, on natukene nüüd rohkem vaja teha. Sellepärast, et If Lausesse ma ei saa panna noineline saab panna, kui, ee, jälle teha mingit väga Fancy koodi,
Õpetaja: mis me Tegelikult, oma teadmiste kohaselt võiks teha kus siin, ennem oli. Pole enam ju mingit,
Õpetaja: Mis seal oli? Voor tühi voor sulud,
Õpetaja: Ee, muutuja nimi In asemel oli mingi muu. Sõna. Oli off. Oli vist vä
Õpetaja: Ee, ei kirjuta igapäevaselt. Ei oska lihtsalt teha.
Õpetaja: No, proovime korra. Ee, teeme Niimoodi, Count. Kõigepealt Let Ee Checked
Õpetaja: transaction Type
Õpetaja: Taip võib ise teha Taip Count.
Õpetaja: Nii, Count algab alati. See on üks muutuja, mida me Kavatseme suurendada, mis tahame algväärtuseks olla, Null onju?
Õpetaja: Mida meie tahame teha? Ma ütlen, kas ta fortsüklit äkki teeb või Ei, tee
Õpetaja: noh, oskab siin ka täita või? Ma ei tea, äkki kas siin käib lett või mitte. Ma ei tea, Lett aa, et me vaatame ühte Transaction Type I korraga.
Õpetaja: See on objekt ja Office oli see, mis lubab kollektsiooni panna. Aa, muutuja nimi algab väikse tähega. Loomulikult
Õpetaja: meil on, mis on meie objekt. Meie objekt on see, kus me ta kätte saame.
Õpetaja: Location Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Nii, Aa, this punkt location punkt ee transaction types.
Õpetaja: See peaks nüüd töötama, niimoodi, et ta teeb fortsüklid siin läbi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd igal tsüklil. Mida meie peame vaatama, et me võtame selle ühe objekti, Kõigepealt on If Lause. Vaata, võta üks transaction Type objekt, Aga ainult üks väli sealt. Täpsemalt,
Õpetaja: mis me tahame.
Õpetaja: Is available oli. Ärge nüüd Seda Tehke mis? Milleks see asi ei peaks rehkenduma Idee järgi juba praegult.
Õpetaja: Kui selle väärtus on True we Falls, siis juba ongi olemas, Onju
Õpetaja: nii? Ma mõtlen. Aa, me saame natukene lihtsamat. Võibolla teha. Ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, kas fortsüklis Javascriptis on olemas? Break, Ma pakun, et ta on, Mis ta teeb? Break
Õpetaja: on see, Kui te teete mingit tsüklit Kui tuleb ette sõna break, siis see tähendab, et katkesta
Õpetaja: see kogu see Tsükkel. Tsau, Baka. Pole mõtet. Kä juba. Ühe. Leiad ülesse
Õpetaja: ühe tulemuse. Siis tegelikult pole enam vahet. Juba, onju nii?
Õpetaja: Aa, mida teeb continue Niukene käsk on ka.
Õpetaja: Continue on niimoodi, et et nüüd selle tsükliga, kui siit isegi tuleb mingit koodi siin allpool veel, näiteks et kõik Tsau, hüppa sellest tsüklist välja. Mine järgmisse tsüklisse,
Õpetaja: et selle objektiga oleme teinud.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei vaatame, Mõtleme, onju? Ee, ma arvan, et Break I on siin vaja
Õpetaja: ja meil ei olegi võibolla seda muutujat vaja Sest nüüd ma saan aru, et me saame selle teistmoodi ära teha,
Õpetaja: Ma Arvan, et ei lähe ma esialgu. Hoiame seda seal. Counter It
Õpetaja: Ee. Kas vastab tõele, et niipea kui meie käime tsükli läbi on ju
Õpetaja: Kui teeme, et see on tsükli läbi, Kui vähemalt üks transaction Type on true, siis meil vist on olemas.
Õpetaja: Nii Kuidas see asi pols?
Õpetaja: No ongi, see on ju See ongi ju.
Õpetaja: See on nagu Kõik on Falseid. Me käime läbi ja vaatame, et kui endiselt ei leia Ühtegi truud. Kas ta läheb If lausesse sisse? Kui kõik on falseid,
Õpetaja: ei lähe Thats the idea. Aga meil on lihtsalt. Vaja. Meil on Mõlemat asja loomulikult. Vaja teada, et kas ta läheb sinna või mitte. Vaata, on ju? Meil on teada, et kui ta läheb siia sisse, Siis me juba tegelikult saaks. Me saaks ka seda siin teha. Me saaksime öelda, et Error messages
Õpetaja: push, ja nüüd ütleme ühe, teate onju, Mis mis see teade on? Vali vähemalt.
Õpetaja: Aa, siia võiks. Teate, mis siit on puudu? Vä.
Õpetaja: Siit on heeder puudu,
Õpetaja: et siin on nagu puudu. Vaata nagu võimalikud tehingutüübid või midagi taolist. Aga ma praegu ei viitsi sellega tegeleda, sest et siin on üliraske nagu öelda, vaata, et Mi Mida sa siit pead valima? Sa võid öelda tehingutüübid ja inimene saaks seda välja mõelda, aga tegelikult on siin vaja koodis parandust teha, Kui me läheme siia
Õpetaja: tähenda. Nüüd tuleb siia kaks Child I.
Õpetaja: Paneme lihtsalt siia Väikse heederi. Mingi H viis tehingu tüübid.
Õpetaja: Kui tegelikult võiks ta isegi label olla. Kas meil siin Aa, meil ei ole?
Õpetaja: Jah, ma ei taha label it panna. Ma panen pigem niimoodi tehingu tüübid
Õpetaja: Või ma ei tea, kuidas. Sa ütled pangaautomaat, et tehingutüübid on nad ka imelik. Vali ja nii
Õpetaja: oli tegevused. Võibolla või oli lubatud toimingud.
Õpetaja: Või vali võimalikud.
Õpetaja: Ei, oota Mida iganes see nimi on. Vaata onju. Issand, miks? Nagu lilla on?
Õpetaja: Vot kas meil on mingi vana Cs S kuskil veel, kui me pullisime ringi. Veits, assets. Style Sss,
Õpetaja: H Viis ajalehed.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast see Body kogu aeg vilgubki Kuule, siit kustutame kõik ära nagu siia. Las ta olla alles. Me saame siia panna pärast asju, kui tahame.
Õpetaja: Aga mina mõtlesin, et tal on mälus kuidagi ja Teil kõigil ka vilgub. Ja.
Õpetaja: No mul muidugi, Ei, Tegelikult, Ma pean ütlema, et ma võibolla ikka panen selle ühe asja tagasi.
Õpetaja: Korra on isegi hea seda vilkumist näha. See annab kiirelt referentsi mulle, et mingi refresh,
Õpetaja: sest et voe kirjutab oma asjaga üle. Tema asi jääb peale,
Õpetaja: Võtan korra Fash I. Ma vaatan, kas on alles okei? Väga hea, Davai. Selge?
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd. See vielet läks. Ära, Vaata et vali võimalikud toimingud. Sest et ma mõtlen, milleks oli seda heederit vaja, on see, et ülikeeruline on midagi, öelda.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, siis jääks allergis öelda, et Vali vähemalt üks toiming.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga kui sul ei ole headerit, siis on, nagu
Õpetaja: ta võib aru saada, mis on mõeldud ja ma saan ka seda punaseks värvida, kui vaja ja nii edasi. Aga see ei ole Mu soov, onju? Praegu Nii siis on vähemalt see, et kui Mina leian vähemalt ühe sõnumi. Siis ma sinna sõnumisse lükkan, et vali vähemalt üks
Õpetaja: võimalik toimingaja.
Õpetaja: Mul On võimalik automaadi Vot hakkab tulema midagi automaadi.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga mul on üks mõte. Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, mul natukene. Nagu nüüd klikis ka ära. Mida ma võibolla tahaks, et see sõnum ole See Heeder oleks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma tulen veel. Täiendan seda ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, midagi taolist oli vähemalt üks.
Õpetaja: No nii, no see on ju kõige lähemalt. Üks Atl toiming.
Õpetaja: Ah Ei, ole. Vaata, kui ma täidan. Ruttu kõik ära. Vaata, Tallinn. Aa, siin juba üks on onju? Lisa.
Õpetaja: Mm, Error.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, oot, oot, oot, oot, jaa, ee. Mul on ju vaja. Ikkagi mul. Mul tundub, et Counterit on ikkagi vaja. Vaata selle võime Võtta nüüd Control Iksiga ja panna siin.
Õpetaja: Ah, ma läksin. Mingi Ee, mul on. Kaob ekraanipilt vahepeal ära. Pane see väljapoole alla, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, ootame korra veel. Ee, sellepärast, et mul ei olegi vaja leida truu. Mul on vaja negatiiv. Mul on Errorit vaja visata.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Ma pean ikkagi tegema niimoodi, et on vaja teha County
Õpetaja: vaja teha Count I. Kui ma leian, et on,
Õpetaja: sest et esimene, kui ma Leian sellest. Mul ei ole ka kasu. Vaata, ma pean kõik läbi käima. Igal juhul,
Õpetaja: Check Count peab olema ikkagi üks Vaata siis, mina Näen, et seda on mõtet niimoodi teha. Seda return Ib. Kui ma leian ühe truu,
Õpetaja: ma korra mõtlen, kui ma leian ühe truu ära. Ee, praegult ma saan. Siis ma. Tegelikult ikkagi tean, et kõik on hästi
Õpetaja: Teeme. Natuke teistmoodi. Ma räägin, räägin kuidas mina nagu seda teeks, Tahaks teha ikkagi seda stiilis, nagu on need siin If. Midagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtame kogu. Selle veel. Ei, mõtle, kurat. Kas seal lähed jalgade ostnud Mina ei jalgade ostnud. Miks see on kogu aeg läbi aastate üks ja see sama asi nagu mul pilt kogu aeg nagu lihtsalt virvendab Ja läheb hästi ära.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma ei usu, sest et see. Tegelikult ma peaksin ütlema. Nagu see monitor vajaks veits vahetust. Kogu aeg vilgub pidevalt Ära Sealt väsitame mind veits. Nii, Ee, teeme siia alla abimeetodi.
Õpetaja: See saab olema Niuke tüüpi Vaata, meetod.
Õpetaja: Ee at least one transaction Taip
Õpetaja: saaks vahepeal jälgi tulla, kohe. Ma teen siis vähemalt selle ära. E Selected.
Õpetaja: Teen selle keha ära ja siis tuleme järgi No nüüd Läks eriti hulluks, Nagu Äkki on asi hoopis selles kohas, kus ta on. Connected? Ei peagi, Mul on see spliter vahel, aga mul ei ole selleks enam. Ee, see ei ole isegi ühenduses.
Õpetaja: Tuleb otse Dok I.
Õpetaja: See siis on kuidagi halvasti ühenduses. Äkki on see vibratsioon.
Õpetaja: Vahetasin pakki ära tulid. Ja võibolla
Õpetaja: jah, sealt Mul tegelikult on vanasti olnud teistsugune. Mul sisetunne ikkagi ütleb, et see on selle monitoriga seotud, ma Teen igale selle push I ära. Ee, ja siis. Kohe räägime edasi.
Õpetaja: Kes järgi tulevad? Käsipüstis? Teen
Õpetaja: kohe. Ütlen, Kui buss on tehtud, olge juba.
Õpetaja: Kas keegi tuleb skript iga ka järgi? Minu meelest ise vist käsite. Saab ikka kiiremini, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Täiega Saate teha juba on, Mis see järjekord on? Mis te teete, Futch?
Õpetaja: Ja siis on checkout.
Õpetaja: Ei ole checkout. New Branch, onju? New Branch ja mingi kiire nimi Ja olemegi. Joonel.
Õpetaja: Peaks kunagi võistlusi tegema. Vaata starte. Siis vaatame, kas kõige kiiremini jõuab.
Õpetaja: Auhinnaks on see, kes kõige kiiremini järgi jõuab. See jõuab kõige kiiremini järgi,
Õpetaja: Mu sõber, Ma olen hästi see Sims. Vaata, kes on meie Niukene seltskonna hing.
Õpetaja: Tal on üks niisugune kuldlause mis Ta on kunagi lihtsalt läbi. Vaata, et see vanasõna. Vaata, et kes hiljaks jääb. Silma jääb siis. Temal on lihtsalt Kes ilma. Jääb see Ilma jääb
Õpetaja: puhas kool.
Õpetaja: Ja sa öelda, et sa ei vasta nagu tõele, et kui sa jääd mingist asjast ilma, siis jääd mingist asjast Ilma nii olete kohal.
Õpetaja: Ootan kedagi. Veel. Käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: Ei ole väga hea.
Õpetaja: Noh, Adren, Mis sa selle käega ikka viipad? Kas nüüd võib Kas nüüd võib?
Õpetaja: Päriselt ka?
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, ma ootan su järgi.
Õpetaja: Ma pigem ootaks pardale. See nagu üks sekund, nagu täna midagi muudab. Ee, Ma panin tähele, et siin nüüd selles meetodis on väike viga. Vaata, see on kaks sõna, On ju?
Õpetaja: Selected. Kujutage ette, kui te näete seda ifis If at least One transaction types Selected.
Õpetaja: Siis Meie jaoks on kõik hästi,
Õpetaja: aga me. Te tegelikult. Huvitab Ee, see, et ei ole. Vaata me tahame seda sama asja, Aga me tahame inversiooni panna.
Õpetaja: Kui ta on inversioon, siis sa oled seda mõttes tagurpidi Selected sellepärast, et Nad on teineteist välistavad. Kas on valitud või ei ole valitud? Siin Ei ole nagu mingit vahepealset varianti.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siis siia me Võtamegi selle sama loogika, mis nüüd on? Me teeme ta veits paremaks. Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee. Võtad. Võtame selle tsükli Võtame, esialgu kopiga Las ta korraks olla. Seal Ei, mõtleme.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et see tsükkel käib läbi.
Õpetaja: Kui ta leiab vähemalt ühe.
Õpetaja: Ta peab tagastama kui ta leiab vähemalt Ühe asja, mis on available, Siis mis ta tegema peab,
Õpetaja: Siis ta peab tagastama True.
Õpetaja: See on Niukene. Hea võte, Mi, Mis, on mida Peab ka valdama, et vastab tõele. Hakkame tsükeldama. Läbi igal tsükli. Võtame ühe transaction type If Lause Sees. Vaatame, et kui Transaction on true, Siis tuleb return. Ida True on nii?
Õpetaja: Return True. Nüüd tagastab selle meetodi
Õpetaja: vastuse. Ta läheb siit ära. Ta rohkem edasi ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Meie teeme niimoodi, et juhul kui ta käib ära. Kõik need ee, variandid, aga mitte korda kihvt sisse ei lange. Ta endiselt peab ju midagi tagastama. Sellepärast, et see meetod on taga mõeldud niimoodi, et ta tagastab puuleni.
Õpetaja: Mida ta siis peab tagastama, kui ta käib kõik tsüklid läbi, aga ei leidnud ühtegi,
Õpetaja: mis on available Mis ta siis tagastab pools?
Õpetaja: See on Jumala hea süsteem, kuidas asju teha,
Õpetaja: niipea, sest et see on. See on suht efektiv ka. Kui see esimene asi. Esimene variant on juba true. Ütleme esimest, Ta saab true, Ta saab oma vastuse kätte ja ongi kõik, on nii? Ta teab, et vaata. Ainult sellisel juhul, kui ta käib kõik läbi
Õpetaja: ja ükski nendest ei ole Truu siis on teada seda, et. Noh, siis tuleb öelda, et
Õpetaja: ei ole ühtegi selectitud.
Õpetaja: Ja meid see nüüd huvitabki.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võib selle siit võib need Count Id ja kõik asjad ära nüüd teha. Nüüd me teeme samamoodi nagu Vali vähemalt üks pangaautomaat, on ju?
Õpetaja: Teeme sellest eelmisest Tublikaadi, Mis me nüüd siin sees teeme?
Õpetaja: Sest et eesmärk on see, et hakkab ütlema. Vali vähemalt
Õpetaja: üks Atm Toiming, mis me siin tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Me tahame kutsuda välja seda abimeetodit This
Õpetaja: at Least One Transaction Taiping Selected.
Õpetaja: Aga ta praegult on, ma, arvan, aga ta praegult on Tagurpidi Saate aru, et
Õpetaja: ta annaks vea, kui vähemalt üks on valitud.
Õpetaja: Aga me tuleme. Paneme nüüd ette selle hüüumärgi ja nüüd see mõte Sellel meetodil muutub.
Õpetaja: Not One Transaction Type Selected
Õpetaja: tähendab see, mõttes. Me peame ise seda niimoodi lugema. Aga mäletate, eitavaid meetodeid ei tohi teha
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui nad eitavalt panna ehitusesse, siis pea tõmbab kooma.
Õpetaja: Me võiks teha niukse meetodi Selected ja siis sa panedki selle niimoodi, siia, If Aa sõnastus vajaks veel natukene timmimist. Siis tule siia sisse. Aga kui sul läheks Jumala eest vaja vastupidist olukorda kuidagi mingil põhjusel, vaadata.
Õpetaja: Siis sa peaksid selle eitava panema uuesti eitavusse. See on nagu väga vale. Ärge tehke, seda
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd vaadata. Kas ta töötab
Õpetaja: küll ta töötab. Noh, loogika ütleb, et peaks töötama.
Õpetaja: No ma valin esialgu need muud asjad ära.
Õpetaja: Ära vaata, et ta jätaks rahule. Vajutan Lisa, vali Vähemalt üks Atm toiming.
Õpetaja: Panin selle. Viimase ei tulnud midagi.
Õpetaja: No teeb Refresh näeb, et See error iseenesest töötab.
Õpetaja: Vali mingi liin. Täida asukohanimi. Vali vähemalt üks Atm toiming.
Õpetaja: Vali mingi linn. Täida asukohanimi.
Õpetaja: No paneme selle nulli. Näiteks saate aru? Töötab ja
Õpetaja: vähemalt üks on selector, Niipea, Kui ei ole, siis ta tuleb juurde.
Õpetaja: Sobib, Aga kas me nagu ei oleks võinud lihtsalt panna, et If Transaction Type märk oleks saanud Sama tulemuse. E.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas ma saan seda kirjutada, kui Transaction types on massiiv? Kui sina ütled, Vaata, Transaction Type siis sina mõtled ainult ühte objekti.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas ma saan seda? Ma korra mängime selle mõttega. Vaata, on ju? No ma teen tublikaadi,
Õpetaja: nagu kohe jääb, nagu teeme Selle hüüumärgi alles hiljem on ju Mis objekti vastu ma vaatan?
Õpetaja: No location I. Sees. On Andmed vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: On?
Õpetaja: No ma alustan sellest Vähemalt location So far so good.
Õpetaja: Ee, kõik variandid on mille sees?
Õpetaja: Transaction types. Aga ta on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Siia Ma ei saa pannabel sellepärast, Et sellepärast, et siin
Õpetaja: sel see ei ole, objekt väljaga. Transaction Type Id, vaid ta on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Ma peaksin siis ütlema ju hoopis niimoodi, et. Kuule, kus sa ta nüüd jäi? Mul siin on ju? Ma peaksin siin Ütlema. Kastid. Vaata palun
Õpetaja: esimest objekti ja ütlen, et kas Tema on True või False. No ma saaks ändidega siin ka panna need asjad ära. Aga ma ju ei tea, mitu objekti seal sees on?
Õpetaja: Isegi kui ma teaksin, siis ma ei teeks ikkagi seda niimoodi. Miks mõttega Ma nagu hakkan mingeid panema?
Õpetaja: Võibolla kunagi tuleb üks objekt juurde. Kas ma siis panen veel neid enda juurde? Vaata,
Õpetaja: et Point on see, et see on massiivne,
Õpetaja: saad aru? See on massiivsed meetod Meetodi see siit Kutsudes sinna. Me siis saame. Massiivne,
Õpetaja: Kuhu siin ei ole? Kas Kas siin on massiiv
Õpetaja: Siin on meetod, mis tagastab True Falls.
Õpetaja: Ja seda sa See saa Wifi sisse panna. Vaatan seda, mis seal all pool on. Alg one, mis siin on
Õpetaja: Vot seal on Kui see on pru, siis annab pruugi. See on pood. Siis anna pood, et nagu
Õpetaja: sa mõtled, et otse törni panna vä või mida sa mõtled,
Õpetaja: mulle tundub lihtsalt nagu enda peas. Võibolla ma ei saa, aru, lihtsalt. Aga teeme nüüd niimoodi. Vaata, et ma kustutan kõigepealt selle siit ära, onju? See mis on, mis ei tööta niikuinii. Teeme siis seda niimoodi, Vaata et. Ee,
Õpetaja: nii. Ma ütlen, et teil on vaja seda näha. Korra natukene. Te peate korra nägema seda füüsiliselt ja et oleks natukene veel parem näha, siis ma teen siia ühe muutuja ka,
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, oleks kuskilt vaadata kohe East available
Õpetaja: value.
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et palun näita, mis siin sees on. Siis on? Siis on lihtsalt nagu lihtsam jälgida. Teeme niimoodi, et ma teen refresh. Ma panen juba inspekt.
Õpetaja: Ma tulen, otsin konsol ülesse.
Õpetaja: Aa Gonsiolis on mingisugused. Ee, Error Id ka peab Siis tegelema sellega. Mingi hetk ka. See. Võibolla praegu oli ajutiselt. Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ma käivitan tegevused, et ee käivituks see, Koht, kus seda valideerimist tehakse ja tuleb see. Olen siin.
Õpetaja: Eesmärk on lihtsalt see link kätte saada.
Õpetaja: Ma panengi Break Point I, aga ma Panen igaks juhuks igale reale, Siis ta jääb tingimata seisma. Kui ee, ma neid näpin niiöelda. Nii, nüüd ma vajutan uuesti seda, Lisa,
Õpetaja: nii Käivitub see koodilõik Vaatame, mida see koodilõik teeb. Ma kahjuks suuremaks Vist ei saa Scrollida siin. See ei muuda seda Niimoodi saan võibolla teha, Kas vist teksti suuremaks ikka ei muuda, onju?
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame, mis siin toimub. Sammsammult. Aa, Next, Vaata, onju Step over function.
Õpetaja: Mis see nupp on? Ma ei tea, see vist ongi Step over. Tuleme siia paremal pool Meil on niiöelda Ee, objekt, kus on tegelikult
Õpetaja: massiiv Siin on Arrae, mis koosneb kolmest objektist. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui mina? Vajutan. Aa, F üheksa. Ma ei julge vajutada. F. Üheksa siin. Nuppe Näitab ka Või Ei, näita.
Õpetaja: Step, F, Kümme. Okei. Ee, nüüd. Kui, mina olen
Õpetaja: aa Lähen, edasi mis. Ta tegi nüüd ta? Võttis esimese objekti sealt
Õpetaja: Ja siin sees on is available väärtus. Kõik need on Falls Id Olete näos.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma nüüd tulen sisse? Mul on järgmisele reale, Me Näeme ka siin eas. Available I sees on false.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis hetkel. Kas ta siia sisse tuleb? Või ei tule.
Õpetaja: Me ju näeme, et väärtus. Siin on kontrollrida. Vaata, et see sama asi on Ju If Lause sees. Onju, et praegult see on False, siis see ei tule Tuleme uuele tsüklile. Võtame järgmise objekti
Õpetaja: nüüd. Järgmine objekt on meil siis
Õpetaja: ee raha välja. See on see keskmine on ju.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis raha välja väärtus on, on nii False. Järelikult see If Lausesse ei tule, on nii?
Õpetaja: Järelikult siia. Return truusse ei satu. Tuleme nüüd kolmandal tsüklil Siin nüüd Transaction Type on meil ee, maksed
Õpetaja: maksed. Väärtus on is. Available on Falls. Järelikult. Kas ta siia If lausesse tuleb, ei tule
Õpetaja: Järelikult kogu Four tsükkel sai läbi Ja nüüd minnakse viimasele koodireale.
Õpetaja: Kui siit oleks returniga, oleksime ära läinud siis siia, me enam ei satuks. Vaata nüüd, ta tagastab, et siis
Õpetaja: At Least One Transaction Type Selected. Ja ta ütleb False,
Õpetaja: sest et mitte ükski nendest ei olnud
Õpetaja: nii, Ma nüüd lasen sellel minna.
Õpetaja: Teeme korra uuesti. Aga nüüd ma panen selle Aa. Panen selle keskmise see on ideaalne et me, näitame seda, Vaata, et me teeme seda asja nii kaua, kuni me saame sellele pihta. Me läheme sinna sisse
Õpetaja: ja siis see meetod tagastab tulemuse ja Läheb Sinna kohta, kus teda välja kutsuti. Viimast seda ei tee. See on nagu,
Õpetaja: noh. Ja avastaks kogu aegida. Vaata, väga mõnusalt. Panen jälle niimoodi, et vajutan seda nuppu. Lisa,
Õpetaja: Aa, mul oli vaja. Olen siin. Kas ma Ei, pannud Break Point I sinna või onju
Õpetaja: Seisabki siin Nii F. Kümnega hakkame. Liikuma tuleme. Esimesel tsüklil
Õpetaja: transaction Type I Sees. On see esimene objekt raha. Sisse tema. Isabelable On false
Õpetaja: On return I sisse ei tule. Tuleme uuel tsüklil. Nüüd on siis see raha välja. Mis on raha väljal is? Available väärtus,
Õpetaja: true.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et see asi siin
Õpetaja: rehkendub truuks. Nüüd, mis juhtub. Me tuleme If bloki sisse. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: See on see keskmine nüüd retööril Lause kehtib Nüüd selle meetodi kohta
Õpetaja: ta nüüd return Ib ja ütleb. See meetod tagastab, et Kuule, at Least One he Selected
Õpetaja: True ja enam uuele tsüklile. Me ei tule,
Õpetaja: Mis tema nüüd läks? Ta tuli selle truuga siia
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: kui praegult seda hüüumärki poleks. See oleks true ja ta Tuleks siia sisse Ja Push Iks. Vali vähemalt üks toiming.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ta sai. Truu, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga meil on see tagurpidi keeratud. See tähendab Seda, et on False.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et ei Tule vali. Vähemalt üks toiming,
Õpetaja: see tuleb. Ma ütlen, et selles mõttes on see hästi Lihtne,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Noh, sellest loogikast. Teil oli natuke vaja aru saada. Tsüklites käime läbi ja ainult siis Ja ainult siis
Õpetaja: tagastab see meetod True, Kui ta komistab niukse transaction type I pihta, millel is available on true. See asi ongi Ju Poole on väärtus True puhul see Meetod ütleb. Ja
Õpetaja: vähemalt üks. Ja nüüd ongi nagu see mugav asi. On see, et me pidime kirjutama selle asja niimoodi. Positiivses võtmes
Õpetaja: ja Siin me keerame selle lihtsalt tagurpidi. See on nii lihtne. Lihtsalt loe seda asja tagurpidi. Kui see ütleb, et One Transaction types Selected, siis Sa pead lugema, et nad One Transaction types Selected mõttes.
Õpetaja: No meetodi nime üle võib mõelda. Nüüd ongi kui If Not One Transaction Type Selected, siis Pushi sõnum. Vali vähemalt üks Atm Toiming
Õpetaja: on see arusaadav.
Õpetaja: See käib niimoodi.
Õpetaja: No nüüd me selle nagu põhimõtteliselt tegime ära, et Meil on kõik asjad kontrollitud. Kas On midagi või ei ole, onju
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd me saame siis, teha et kogu see asi, Mis siin, oli,
Õpetaja: et ta kogub kokku massiivi nendest andmetest. Error Message, Ta topib need lõpuks siia Error, message isse
Õpetaja: ja nüüd vaadake, Ad Location. Esimene asi on see, et validate Forum Correct Import. No see ongi see.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ta ütleb, et kui on mingisugune viga
Õpetaja: vabandust, Kui Error messed on tühi siis saada sõnum. Pack. I.
Õpetaja: See kuvamine tuleb juba siit. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kuvamine. See, et tuleb see alert juba tuleb Siit sellest kohast siit alert tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aga me sõnumi saatmisesse mitte kunagi ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Kui Erl Message on. Clean on suht Niukene lihtne loogiline loogika.
Õpetaja: Me kontrollime seda, et ennem me edasi ei lähe. Kui sa esimese korraga täidad, kõik kohe. Ära. Vaata, valid linna.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta mõtleb Siin toob Stoplight Ist andmeid.
Õpetaja: Närvits on siin.
Õpetaja: Valin Tallinna. Aa, siin on juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Kas all eriti tuleb?
Õpetaja: Ei, tule. See Tähendab seda, et ee, sinna If lausesse. Me läheme sellepärast. Error Message on tühi.
Õpetaja: Siia saaks panna. Vaata ajutiselt niimoodi. Hästi, kiiret, alert, et oleks midagi meil näha saada. Panen.
Õpetaja: Saatsin Packi uue Location I.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: teen refresh Ma pean nüüd uuesti täitma, et kood nagu oleks valiidne bla blabla. Aa, vali üks. See Kõik asjad on täidetud. Error Message on tühi.
Õpetaja: Ei,
Õpetaja: no vaatame korra Veel Refresh, ma arvan, et see on mingi Jama nagu praegult.
Õpetaja: Noh, noh, laegab võimalust ja nii
Õpetaja: saate ma tast aru. Kui on tühi sõnum, läheb aga selle valideerimise seas me valideerime Ära vaata, et kas vorm on korrektselt täidetav.
Õpetaja: Niukene, Suht kaval võte.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ainukene asi. Võibolla. Mis võiks veel mõelda, on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: See asi siin.
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd teen ka peast selles mõttes. Vaata, et, ee, see sama string, mis siin on. Vaata, sees on selle hetkega, Kui ütleme two String Ta, muutub string. Iks
Õpetaja: Võiks panna selle mingi muutuasse see. On objekt vaata. Parem pool peab Rehkenduma välja ennem kui Vasakule poolele saad anda sisu
Õpetaja: Ee stringil peaks olema Niukene meetod nagu Replace.
Õpetaja: Näed, replős. Replace on niimoodi, et Search Value
Õpetaja: ja peale koma Peaksid panema Replace Value Search Value Replace. Value, mida meie tahame otsida. Otsi koma.
Õpetaja: Näiteks otsige oma Replace otsi koma
Õpetaja: ja millega me tahame seda asendada Tahame Stringiga Tühik. Ei, no koma tühik.
Õpetaja: Saate aru. Ta Teeb nagu kaks asja korraga. Võta see error. Message. Massiiv, Tee see Stringiks. Stringil on meetod. Replace. Selle sama teksti ees mis meil siin on. See on tekst juba selleks hetkeks. Otsi sealt koma. Asenda see Koma tühik.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis, kui me nüüd praegu proovime, Refresh,
Õpetaja: siis ta juba näeb natukene parem välja, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui tahaksime, me saaksime ka siin mudida, et me teeme üldse Html I sellest ja Break või midagi taolist. Nad on üksteise. Ma ei tea, kas nii saab. Vaata, Ma korra proovin. Ma ei tea, kuidas ta tõlgendab, kuna ta on. Ma Ei, ma ei tea, ta on seal sees kuskil, kus kohas ta on. Vaata, ta on Alerdis, on ju? Korra? Vaatan, kuhu. Kuhu sa kukud üldse?
Õpetaja: Ta kukub ainult siia vahele. See koht aksepteerib tegelikult Html I võib proovida pulli pärast.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kui ma ütleksin, et ee. Siin sees
Õpetaja: sellest ringi, sees et koma asenda, Hoopis
Õpetaja: ma ei mäleta. Ka. Ma proovin kohe. Lihtsalt. Pr onju Üksik tag, Võibolla minevik.
Õpetaja: Ei, ta ikka Replace. Kõik
Õpetaja: peaks tegema. Aa, okei, ja sul on Õigus, Aa, See on jäetud selleks võimaluseks, et kui sa tahad.
Õpetaja: Aa, sul on õigus. Replace Soul. Aa, Replays. No peaks olema. Kindlasti midagi
Õpetaja: Otsi neid ja asenda. Võin panna siia Html Tag i Break.
Õpetaja: Proovime.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ta nüüd? Teeb
Õpetaja: Open vä, kus see tuli?
Õpetaja: No jah, Okei, tema jaoks on see ikkagi String
Õpetaja: Ma ei viitsi mõelda. Seda Pra, Oota korra. Line Break.
Õpetaja: Kas ta lubab siin? Muidugi ma ei tea, räägid.
Õpetaja: No Okei, Ee, ma tahan kohe lihtsalt küsime. Vaata abi, lihtsalt nagu. Mis me siin ikka jaurame?
Õpetaja: Nii, Ütlen talle, Selected Kas saaks. Nii et tekstis jäävad New Line.
Õpetaja: Ta peab natukene detailsemalt vaatama, sest ta tegelikult ta peab arvestama. Kuhu see on metsats kukub, ta Kukub tavalise pilvide vahele.
Õpetaja: Ma annan talle ette. Vaata Ütlen talle, et ta lõpus on siin. Vahel
Õpetaja: Selected.
Õpetaja: Ta lõpuks on seal vahel
Õpetaja: Style White Space Preline.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: jah, aga, noh, nüüd me ajamegi siin Ee, paika. Mingisugused idiootsused, mida te saate oma töödes teha, niikuin, ise et Lubasin, et seda ei tee ja ei teegi. Mine sa ka, oota. Kas ta vahetus juba, ära onju?
Õpetaja: Style ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Mul on midagi siin valesti. Arvatavasti jah.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi vist nüüd selle koodi korda. Siin kuskil. Kus see nüüd see on?
Õpetaja: Join?
Õpetaja: Aa, Niukene. Käsklus on ka. Kohe, vaata. Lihtsalt pane massiiv kokku. Join idega, Vaatame, mis tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aga ausõna, sellest kaugele ma nüüd ju purjetan, et nagu, et tuleb, mis tuleb. Noh, olete rahul.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga Kas seda on ikkagi vaja? Nüüd ma küsin seda. Seda on ikka vaja.
Õpetaja: Kas see On ikka vajalik.
Õpetaja: Ahah Okei, ignoreerib vaid. Okei, noh, Davai, mida iganes. Ee, saime selle kätte.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis võibolla nüüd kiirkorras võiks siis proovida seda ka et, ee. Teeks siis selle sõnumisse saatmise osa ära. Me peame niikuinii sellega tegelema, et nii palju kui jõuame,
Õpetaja: Ee, sõnumi saatmine, Mis me siis ee, teeme?
Õpetaja: See peaks olema juba teil nagu unepealt tulema. Vaikselt Kuidas piiblist. Muidugi Piibel.
Õpetaja: Postsõnum.
Õpetaja: Postsõnum. Kuhu see, kuhu see Postsõnum tuleb teeks kõigepealt selle ära, et kuhu me nagu reaalselt saadame Selle osa, mis saadab sõnumi välja süsteemist, kus see võiks minna,
Õpetaja: kuhu võiks minna. Kuhu me hakkame seda piiblit timmima, nagu. Vaata, sõnum on. Ee, see sõnum siin on ju
Õpetaja: Notation.
Õpetaja: See Me tahame välja kutsuda. Ma tahan nagu sõna otseses mõttes sõnumi saatmist meie süsteemist välja. Kuhu me selle tahaks panna?
Õpetaja: Trigerdame. See oli hiljem, Vaata, et nagu.
Õpetaja: Kust Tuleb see asi, mis nagu saadab välja põhimõtteliselt selge.
Õpetaja: Uus service. No vaatame
Õpetaja: aga. Post Atm Location see Võiks minna. Location Service Seal olete Nõus,
Õpetaja: siin on Get Atm Locations. Mulle meeldib ee jälgida. Meetodite järjekorras?
Õpetaja: Ee, get. Update delete. Ehk siis uus meetod võiks siia tulla Meetodi nimi on ülilihtne, mis? Ma kirjutan meetodi nimeks
Õpetaja: Post. Aa ei ole send Post
Õpetaja: urli pealt, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd Kohe Võib ära panna et tegemist Ee, on mingisuguse promisobjektiga. Ta peab ka ütlema, et kas läks läbi või Mitte
Õpetaja: nii see sõnum on meil. See juba sobib meil ideaalselt, mis Ta, ütleb parameetrite kohta. See tähendab Urli parameetreid. Aga nüüd on üks väike konks. Okei, mis on järgmised? Ee, tähed, mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelikult on vaja üks asi ennem ühele asjale viidata. Kuidas me saame sõnumit saata? Tehnoloogia
Õpetaja: aktsias on see kes kasutab Fetch i taustal Fetch Api D. Aga meie. Kas saadame aktsiasega sõnumit? Punkt,
Õpetaja: Mis ma. Nüüd kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Post
Õpetaja: nüüd postiga. Nüüd tuleb tähele panna. Meil on esimest korda midagi uut. Ma korra panen selle suureks. Control B,
Õpetaja: mis siin silma jääb?
Õpetaja: Võrreldes ketiga Siin on midagi natuke. Teistmoodi mida ja sport, Kõigil on,
Õpetaja: et siin on keegi ütles ühe numbri. Vaata, ütles midagi.
Õpetaja: Võimalik.
Õpetaja: Siin on kolm muutujat, mis saab sisse minna? Mida me tähele Paneme siin. Ee, nende küsimärkidega.
Õpetaja: Kaks tükki on valikulised, et Url on. Igal juhul on ju Okei, Url on igal juhul urliks. On meil See sama
Õpetaja: Ei, Atm Location.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Mis on järgmine asi, mis siin pakutakse? Mis siin on, mis läks särama. Mis see muutuja nimi ütleb,
Õpetaja: Data. Selle all on nüüd mõeldud objekti.
Õpetaja: Kus on selline info sees? See ongi, Data. Mäletate, kui meil on respons? Punkt? Data, see Nüüd on Request
Õpetaja: Data, mis me tahame saata. Siia peab tulema siis see objekt, mille me tahame saata.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin on üks väikene konks.
Õpetaja: Postitest saab. Niimoodi Infot saab ka niimoodi lisada, et me anname parameetritega kaasa mingit infot,
Õpetaja: et siin on nüüd alati vaja tähtis ühte asja teada.
Õpetaja: See järjekord. Data, tuleb siia. Ja kui sul on veel mingisuguseid.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on mingit veel vaja, siis see tuleb siia viimasele kohale Konfig, Näed, praegu on tata. Ma panen korra siia ka lihtsalt objekti. Vaata, siis ta joonistab välja,
Õpetaja: saate aru, Siin on kolm asja,
Õpetaja: kui Data on niimoodi, et kui sul on Niukene teenus, et te tegelikult ei soovigi Jasonit panna, vaid lihtsalt Urlis lähevad parameetritena mingi info, Sa lisad andmeid Süsteemi on boss sõnum,
Õpetaja: aga ta on nii lihtne lisamine. Ma toon näite. Näiteks Tahad ühte linna juurde lisada? Linna?
Õpetaja: Mul ei ole vaja teha selle jaoks Jason objekti ja panna sinna mingi City name. Ta on lihtsalt saada post parameeter City Name ja saadan purlis selle eest. See on nii lihtne. Vaata,
Õpetaja: siis. Te peate alati jälgima seda, Vaata, et kui te soovite mingisugust konfiga asja teha, Vaata, probleem ongi selles. Vaata, nad on mõlemad objektid. Mõlemad objektid.
Õpetaja: Kui te tahate mingit konfigatsiooni teha,
Õpetaja: siis te peate selle data panema. See on niukene bitfall Alati töödes. Kuskil kellegil on.
Õpetaja: Te tahate konfigi panna? Siis te peate panema tata nulli ja nüüd tulete siia. Panete. Vaata selle params, ma korra teen. Vaata, ma kustutan selle ära, onju? Params.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma teen siia mingi paramuse ja panen mingi ee Näiteks mingi first name.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma panengi lihtsalt City Name. Näiteks City Name. Ma kujutan ette, et City name,
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, bla. Kujutab, et see ongi see objekt
Õpetaja: Ja pane see mingi väärtuse ka praegu, et ta jätaks rahule,
Õpetaja: kui seda nalli siin pole. Vaadake praegult. See konfig. Objekt on see siin, Ta on õigel positsioonil.
Õpetaja: Kui te ei pane seda, siis mis nüüd Tegelikult, see konfiga objekt on? Hoopis
Õpetaja: ta mõtleb, et see on see Jason. Sõnum, mis läheb sõnumiga kaasa. Üli klassikal staff. Kui ei ole kogemust,
Õpetaja: sest et ei pane kohe tähele, sest midagi põlema otseselt ei lähe. Aga ma tahangi saata niukest objekti,
Õpetaja: kus seal on sees Param See City name ja mingi sees. See on minu õigus, aga see on nagu tema jaoks andmed. Ta peaks selle Jasonina kaasa. Aga teil läheb kõik asjad katki. Päk ei tööta, Päk ei tööta, siin peab seda jälgima, Aga meil on praegu hoopis teistsugune olukord. Siit peabki minema. Data,
Õpetaja: Data peab minema.
Õpetaja: No mis? On see meie data, mis on See meie objekt, mida me tahame saata.
Õpetaja: Mis on see Meie objekt, mida Meie tahame? Saata oleme pusinud. See on selle kallal kõvasti
Õpetaja: See Location Objekt, kus ta asub? Meil
Õpetaja: Location Use. Nüüd see meetod ei tea oma elust ööd ega mütsi, on nii? Ta ei ole Connected, Mitte millegagi ta ei ole seotud. Ta on. Ta ei ole millega seotud.
Õpetaja: Siis Me peame tegema selle meetodi selliseks,
Õpetaja: et seda on võimalik käivitada ja on võimalik seda location asja siia kaasa anda, Siis mis me teeme?
Õpetaja: Me peame midagi nüüd tegema. Vaata, sest et me nagu Seisame selle küna ees et, me pea tahame saata seda sõnumit
Õpetaja: seda siin aga, nüüd on vaja luua niuke Võimekus millest, ma räägin kuidas, Impordist.
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha midagi siin importida kuskilt teises klassis. See Location Service see. Meetod Location ei tohi olla millegiga seotud. Ma saan teda kasutada korduvalt, kui tahan. Aga ta ei ole mitte millegiga seotud. Ta on eraldi seisev koodiliik,
Õpetaja: aga mul on vaja andmeid. Nähtavasti mul on Vaja andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, see on just see, mida ma räägin. Mida me ei taha teha. Me ei taha, et see koodilõik on kuidagi seotud. Location View Ga
Õpetaja: ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ei ole. Tema on meetod. Tema on korduvkasutatav kood. Tema ei ole seotud, mitte millegagi
Õpetaja: teda saab kasutada, Aga meil on vaja. Siin Selles tegevuses on vaja neid andmeid. Back end ile saata, et Näe, Lisa, palun üks uus Location. Siis
Õpetaja: nüüd On meil vaja midagi teha selle meetodiga et lisada tal see võimekus, et mul mul on küsimärk. Ma tahan siia. Ma tahan siit panna Midagi, nagu ma tahan, et siit lähevadki need location andmed. Aga näed kogu see meetodi. Tema elu on
Õpetaja: nende kolme poodi real praegult. Kuidas ma Saan muuta seda asja, et Oi, saan lihaseks Juba
Õpetaja: silt. Silt. Mis silt?
Õpetaja: No väga tore. Aga nüüd nüüd vot juba tuli paremat juttu siit kuskilt.
Õpetaja: Mida params mis? Ma ei ole veel kindel, Params.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei,
Õpetaja: Palun öelge Mis reale, mida ma kirjutan, Kõik, mis ma soovin. Lihtsalt öelge mulle järgmised tähed. Kuhu reale ma kirjutan? Mida ma kirjutan. Kuhu Mida
Õpetaja: silt oli juba õige, nagu see oli ah viies rida. Kuhu ma viiendasse? Reasse kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Sulgude vahele. Mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Mida, Mida saab sellesse sulgudesse kirjutada? Mis asi see on, ah?
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: Location? Väga hea, mis asi see on? See on silt. Aga mis silt ta on? Ta on eriline silt.
Õpetaja: Meetodide struktuur, Mis ta on
Õpetaja: parameeter mille jaoks, ta on kaasaantav info selle koodilõigu jaoks. Palun tehke uuesti Jälle lahti. See parameetri õpetus. Meetodi struktuur
Õpetaja: siia Me saame luua sildikese. Kui sa tahad anda mingeid andmeid kaasa, Me ei taha seda. Me ei taha seda lu seda asja millegiga siduda. Me Ei, taha Location View ga siduda. Location View tahab ennast selle asjaga siduda, et tema tahab kasutada siit neid asju
Õpetaja: kui sa käivitad Mingi tegevuse. Sul on selle jaoks vaja andmeid. Siis sa kirjutad mingi parameetri.
Õpetaja: See on sildikene Location.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa ütled, palun?
Õpetaja: On Ad Location. Kõik Done sõnumi saatmine on tehtud.
Õpetaja: Ütle lihtsalt Location Service punkt siia kaasa. Mingi objekt? Noh, ma nüüd teen seda siit sellest ajast, et ma pean jooksma. Aa kontroll. N. Viimane kiire Järk All Location view location view. Kus meil on see õnnelik
Õpetaja: See on see õnnelik Koht saadab äk Ile sõnum, mis ma ütlen siis. Location Service.
Õpetaja: Mis ma nüüd kirjutan, Punkt,
Õpetaja: mida tema ootab. Sisse Anna mulle mingi info, Anna Mingi location. Kus ma selle saan?
Õpetaja: Kõik Nii, Control. Commit.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaugemale üheksa. Ei, jõua thats It
Õpetaja: palun Ee. Teil ikka Läks aega. Selle asjaga.
Õpetaja: Hakake õppima meetodi struktuuri uuesti ja uuesti. Senikaua, kuni te saate aru, Teil on vaja aru saada. Te oleks pidanud juba taibama. Tegelt me oleme rääkinud sellest korduvalt korduvalt.
Õpetaja: Meetod ei tea oma välisest elust ööd ega mütsi Kui on mingid tegevused
Õpetaja: vajavad mingeid andmeid, siis Tuleb see sinna meetodisse kaasa anda. Ta ei saa kuskile. Sa Ei saa progeda, et mine võta sealt Location Viewst mingi reaalselt andmed, isegi Kui saaks, siis ta on Forever and Ever seotud selle Location view ga Kõik kuidagi muud moodi ei saa kasutada. Seda ma tegelikult teha ei taha
Õpetaja: nii. Kuulge, aitab. Aa, kuidas oli see nädal.